bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette suite de nos conférences de
paléo neurologie on a vu les eaux
minines on a vu les cétacés on a vu les
proboscidiens maintenant on va sortir
des mammifères et on va aller lorgner du
côté des reptiles vers une espèce en
particulier un dinosaure tyrannosaurus
rex probablement le plus connu de tous
les dinosaures j'ai envie de dire celui
qui a bercé notre enfance celui qui a
hanté nos cauchemars etc etc
tyrannosaurus rex pourquoi faire une
vidéo en particulier pourquoi sur les
milliers de reptiles j'ai envie de dire
qu'on connaît et sur le presque 800
genre voire 900 genre de dinosaures
connues pourquoi s'arrêter sur
tyrannosaurus rex en particulier au delà
du fait qu'il est super cool
et bas il ya plusieurs raisons à cela
plusieurs raisons scientifiquement
validés j'ai envie de dire de s'arrêter
particulièrement sur tyrannosaurus rex
faut voir qu'aujourd'hui toute la
conférence sera exclusivement consacré à
cette seule espèce est la première
raison pour laquelle on va s'intéresser
exclusivement à cette seule espèce c'est
parce que à part les espèces du genre
homo tyrannosaurus rex et l' espèce
fossile la plus connue il existe des
milliers de fossiles littéralement il ya
vraiment des milliers de spécimens
fossiles qui sont retrouvés de
tyrannosaurus rex pour une raison très
simple c'est que ce tyrannosaurus rex
est l'une des espèces le dîner de
dinosaures les plus jeunes dans le sens
où bas c'est une des dernières c'est une
de celles qui a pris la météorite dans
la tronche donc c'est ca était par
définition une des dernières espèces de
dinosaures qui a vécu donc elle est très
récente et donc aller mieux documenté
que les espèces plus anciennes
déjà première raison deuxième raison
pour laquelle on a beaucoup de fossiles
de tyrannosaurus rex comme c'est une
espace iconique les gens cherchent
activement évidemment les paléontologues
en cherchent activement et aussi on a un
registre fossile qui est très très bon
tyrannosaurus rex il a vécu en amérique
du nord à la fin du crétacé et on a des
dépôts absolument gigantesque de
sédiments qui correspondent à cette
période à la fin du crétacé en amérique
du nord dont il ya beaucoup beaucoup
chances que ces t-rex soit fossilisé
donc on a énormément de fossiles de
tyrannosaurus rex ce qui permet aux
paléontologues de reconstituer beaucoup
d'aspects de la biologie de ces t-rex
comme par exemple la croissance on a on
a des tyrannosaurus depuis les plus
jeunes stade de croissance jusqu'aux
plus anciens il ya eu une période d'une
période il ya eu un moment dans
l'histoire des sciences où on se
demander s'il n'y avait pas une autre
espèce de tyrannosauridés qui s'appelait
nano tyrannus qui était un petit
tyrannosauridés non en fait nano
tyrannus tout semble indiquer que c'est
en fait un t-rex juvénile et que les
t-rex juvénile avait une tronche à ces
différentes jeu des t-rex adultes là
c'est ce que vous voyez là le vouvoyer
les proportions du nez par exemple qui
change vous avez les proportions la
profondeur du crâne donc la profondeur
c'est vraiment c'est comme une baignoire
si vous aussi vous vous représentez le
crâne de dire de t-rex comme une
baignoire retournez vous voyez que les
juvéniles c'est une baignoire moins
profondes donc c'est ça qu'on appelle la
profondeur du crâne c'est l'épaisseur
jeu faut que j'arrête avec mes baignoire
sadia grave
donc voilà on a beaucoup de fossiles de
tyrannosaurus rex depuis l'état juvénile
jusqu à l'état adulte on arrive même à
déterminer grâce à des sections dans les
eaux quel âge quel âge il avait donc on
arrive à savoir à quel âge tyrannosaurus
rex atteignait sa taille adulte donc
vous voyez à peu près vers l'âge de 20
ans tyrannosaurus rex avait finalement
une vie assez proche de la nôtre pour un
animal de 7 tonnes c'est de 5 à 7 tonnes
c'est à ce remarquable puisque à l'âge
de 20 ans à peu près il atteignait sa
taille adulte comme nous et ils avaient
vous voyez une belle puberté la courbe
de croissance qui s'accroissent
soudainement au milieu de sa vie là bas
c'est la belle puberté autour des 15 ans
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle les
subadulte mais on peut appeler ça dd on
peut appeler ça des adolescents
on sait que comme l'être humain
d'ailleurs tyrannosaurus rex avait aussi
des mâles et des femelles bien que ça a
été remis en question récemment avec
l'article de l'article dont je parle
déjà j'ai fait toute une vidéo sur il ya
quelqu'un en fait qui qui a proposé
qu'il y avait plusieurs espèces de
tyrannosaurus et pas seulement tirano
russ rex
mais ça a plus de chance quand même
d'être du dimorphisme sexuel donc des
mâles et des femelles et j'ai déjà fait
une vidéo là dessus donc fait moi penser
à vous la mettre en lien là si je ne
l'ait pas fait faites moi signe dans les
commentaires et je vous la met très en
lien
donc on a des mâles et des femelles de
tyrannosaurus et ça on le sait parce
qu'on a beaucoup de faux cils on a plane
juvénile et ça on le sait parce qu'on a
beaucoup de fossiles on a des séquences
de croissance via documenté bref on a
énormément de connaissances sur la
biologie de tyrannosaurus rex mais ça ça
le rend d'autant plus intéressant à
étudier
donc plus on le connaît et plus on a
envie de le connaître finalement j'ai
envie de dire et tyrannosaurus rex est
d'autant plus connu il est d'autant plus
intéressant qu'on en a fait d'excellents
sites is khan alors vous vous rappelez
je vous ai évoqué la dernière fois la
difficulté qu'on avait à passer des gros
fossiles dans des scanners et bien
brochu en 2003 s'est payé le luxe de
scanner sous le fameux
tyrannosaurus rex quasiment complet qui
avait été découvert quelques années
auparavant donc il s'est payé le luxe
d'aller scanner soudan un scanner de
boeing en fait donc là l'industrie
aéronautique boeing s'est proposé c'est
gentiment proposé de scanner sioux alors
évidemment quand on travaille avec un
tyrannosaurus tout de suite c'est
iconique donc évidemment ça attire ça
attire l'attention donc c'est celle
avantage aussi de travailler avec une
espèce iconiques comme tyrannosaurus rex
c'est qu'on obtient beaucoup plus
facilement des données qui serait
extrêmement difficile voire impossible à
obtenir autrement donc voila vous vous
ramener avec un éléphant random j'ai
envie de dire oui bon super mais vous
vous ramener avec un tyrannosaurus rex
tout de suite et kachi du voyez donc
grâce à brochu et aux efforts aussi de
larry witt maire larry witt meur dont le
laboratoire a produit cette vidéo vous
êtes en train de voir grâce aux efforts
de brochu et de larry witt meurt on a
plusieurs scan maintenant de
tyrannosaurus qui sont utilisables pour
la recherche et qui ont été utilisés
pour la recherche chose qu'on a beaucoup
de mal à produire pour d'autres
dinosaures mais quand il s'agit de
tyrannosaure bas tout de suite ça sorte
plus vite voilà
donc donc on a ces scans qui ont pu être
utilisés pour la recherche et vous voyez
par exemple ici c'est l'endocrâne donc
le moulage de la cavité crânienne de
tyrannosaurus qui vous est représenté
sur cette image
évidemment tyrannosaurus rex mais je l'
ai déjà dit et répété mais au moins
trois fois pendant cette introduction
tyrannosaurus rex est iconique c'est une
espèce qui est extrêmement célèbre et
qui a connu son heure de gloire au fil
de différents produits culturels j'ai
envie de dire le dernier d'entre eux
étant la saga jurassic park et jurassic
world qui ont réellement iconiser à fond
tyrannosaurus rex
donc il ya vraiment il ya vraiment une
aura fait autour de cette espèce qui
donne envie de l'étudier et qui de fait
aussi bâtir les financements et quand
vous attirer les financements ça devient
d'autant plus facile de produire de la
grosse recherche de la de produire des
bonnes données parce que si vous n'avez
pas à vous à trop vous inquiétez de
l'argent que ça va coûter immédiatement
bîmes ça devient plus facile il ya aussi
notre réseau assabah c'est que si vous
voulez il ya beaucoup d'idées reçues qui
sont allés avec ses produits culturels
notamment jurassic park jeu et c'est là
que ça va devenir intéressant niveau
paléo neurologiques c'est que dans
jurassic park il ya plein de d'idées
reçues qui ont été diffusées à propos de
tyrannosaurus rex de ses organes des
sens et de ça et de son comportement
donc par exemple cette scène que vous
voyez devant vous il ne te verra pas si
tu ne bouges pas déclare alan grant en
face du tyrannosaure pour sauver la
petite fille l'ex des dents acérées des
crocs acérés du grand carnivore donc il
ne te verra pas si tu ne bouge pas voilà
là on a une une hypothèse qui a été fait
sur les organes des sens la vue les
organes des sens donc la vue de
tyrannosaurus rex ça impose aussi
d'autres de nombreuses autres hypothèses
ça veut dire que tyrannosaurus rex ne te
verra pas si tu ne bouge pas mais ça
veut aussi dire qu'il te renifleur a pas
non plus bah oui a évidemment le nez là
vous voyez bien que et là il est juste
devant eux et là ça pue le mammifère
mouillé ici là il pleut donc s'il ne te
voit pas il te dois pas non plus pouvoir
te renifler sinon il te mangera il ne
peut pas tendre non plus hein
si si vous voulez passer inaperçu faut
pas non plus que tyrannosaurus rex
puisse vous entendre il faut pas il ya
par exemple dans jurassic park 2 il y à
des hypothèses qui sont faits quant aux
soins parental de tyrannosaurus rex on
voit tyrannosaurus rex
avoir des soins parentaux ou une
attention particulière envers le petit
dans jurassic world on voit
tyrannosaurus rex se battre avec un
autre dinosaure il ya jurassic park iii
aussi on le voit se battre avec d'autres
dinosaures ça implique une forme de
territorialité donc tout ça tout ça ce
sont des hypothèses qui sont faites sur
le comportement de tyrannosaurus rex sur
ses organes des sens tout ça ça c'est
directement lié à ça paléo neurologie
donc aujourd'hui on va voir la paléo
neurologie de t-rex et jusqu'à quel
point ces hypothèses sont réellement
soutenu par les données ou pas il s'agit
pas de des bunkers et jurassic park et
le jurassique world il s'agit de s'en
servir de s'en servir comme support pour
expliquer de la vraie science donc c'est
pas la peine de venir m'expliquer en
commentaire à quel point c'est de la
fiction je suis au courant
c'est de la fiction oui mais je m'en
sers comme support en fait pour pouvoir
vous expliquer des choses sur la science
je ne suis pas là pour critiquer j'ai
suffisamment critiqué la saga jurassic
comme ça et je le fais encore
suffisamment dans une autre série de
vidéos qui s'appelle les analyses de
séquences donc on va pas s'arrêter là
dessus ce qui est vraiment important ici
c'est en fait de partir d'une base en
fait que tout le monde ou presque
connaît à savoir jurassic park et la
culture populaire pour construire de la
science de la communication scientifique
par dessus ça donc on commence par cette
scène justement il ne te verra pas si tu
ne bouges pas oui mais il peut te
renifler parce que son nez et coller
littéralement sur toi et tyrannosaurus
rex a effectivement de très gros bulbe
olfactif donc ici vous voyez trois
crânes de dinosaure tyrannosaurus aloses
aux russes et un adro zor et de
montauzon russe qui est un herbivore
avec deux canards comme vous pouvez voir
et donc quand on regarde le cerveau de
tyrannosaurus on constate quelque chose
de très important les bulbes olfactifs
sont absolument gigantesque et ses
bulbes olfactifs absolument gigantesques
ils forment quasiment la moitié du
système nerveux central de tyrannosaurus
tyrannosaurus définitivement était
capable de renifler et pas qu'un peu
donc il avait d'ailleurs oui j'en
profite pour repréciser
pour repréciser un truc que j'ai déjà
dit plein de fois mais si c'est la
première vidéo que vous regardez sur ma
série sur la paléo neurologie si si vous
venez d'arriver et il ya des chances
puisque tyrannosaurus rex généralement
ça attire des gens donc si vous venez
d'arriver sachez qu'en paléo neurologie
il ya procédé tout bête mais que non
hélas on ne peut pas se défaire c'est
qu'on ne va faire des hypothèses sur la
fonction des organes des sens que
uniquement que basé sur la dimension de
ses organes des sens en gros plus c'est
gros plus c'est utile et mieux ça marche
plus c'est gros et mieux ça marche
d'ailleurs plus que utile on va dire
plus c'est gros et mieux ça marche ça
veut pas dire que c'est vrai
mais c'est hélas la seule chose sur
laquelle on peut travailler on n'a pas
deux neurones préserver dans le registre
fossile on n'a aucun cerveau préserver
dans le registre fossile on n'a que des
andes au crâne et c'est en doc ran ne
sont que des moulages approximatif des
structures neural qui l'enfermé des
structures neurologique que c'est que
ces cavités enfermé donc là ce que vous
voyez c'est la cavité des bulbes
olfactifs ce ne sont pas les bulbes
olfactifs elle même est ici ce que vous
voyez c'est l'endocrâne c'est à dire la
cavité endocrânienne pas le cerveau
directement est ce que vous voyez au
tour ce sont les tuyaux les tubes à
l'intérieur du crâne qui
conduisait les nerfs vers l'extérieur du
crâne donc ici ce qu'on a c'est de très
gros loeb effectif de très très grosses
qualités pour les nobles factice mais
arrêté de dire cavité à chaque fois
maintenant on se comprend de très gros
loeb l'ufac tiff qui indique donc que
tyrannosaurus était tout à fait capable
de renifler ça nous suggère très
fortement que tyrannosaurus était avait
un sens de l'olfaction suffisamment
développé pour pour arriver à renifler
alan grant quand il était juste devant
lui ça d'ailleurs servi de support à la
théorie selon laquelle tyrannosaurus
pouvait être éventuellement un
charognard puisque les charognards tels
que les vautours ont de très gros l'ogbl
fakty fsa leur permet de sentir les les
carcasses pourrissante à plusieurs
kilomètres néanmoins quand on compare
tyrannosaurus à d'autres dinosaures et
notamment d'autres tirs aux dinosaures
théropodes comme la halle aux russes eh
bien on constate que finalement c'est
loeb le fact ifa tyrannosaurus sont pas
si gigantesque que ça c'est à dire
qu'ils sont gigantesques parce que
tyrannosaurus est gigantesque même
comparé à un hâle aux russes
dans le tyrannosaurus est plus gros
qu'un halo zaurus déjà en taille absolue
donc forcément il a des lobes half
actifs qui entaillent absolue son plus
gros cadeau au russe ceci dit relatifs
aux dimensions de l'endocrâne donc
relatif au reste du système nerveux
c'est le wolf actifs sont pas
spécialement gros et même quand on
compare à un herbivore comme edmond
taurus vous voyez c'est loeb half actifs
sont pas si gros que ça
et ça a été confirmée par des analyses
des années des mesures qui ont été
faites sur les lobes effectifs donc ici
vous avez lowball fac tiff en ici à la
verticale et la taille du corps à
l'horizontale
donc ça veut dire qu'en gros on mesure
la taille des lots wolf actifs par
rapport à la taille du corps et quand on
ramène tout ça à la taille du corps au
final tyrannosaurus il est suffisamment
proche d'autres tyrannosauridés mais
vous voyez là vous avez la courbe de
régression qui vous indiquent entre
guillemets la normale la moyenne de la
condition chez les autres dinosaures
voyez que plus on s'éloigne en fait de
cette courbe pas de cette droite de
régression vers le haut et plus on a des
gros lots golf actif et plus on s'en
éloigne vers le bas et moins on a de
gros la wolf actif et vous voyez que
finalement tyrannosaurus ne s'éloigne
pas d autres tyrannosauridés et ne
s'éloignent pas non plus par exemple de
la condition chez les crocodiles moderne
d'après la taille des lobes half actif
la taille relative des lobes olfactif
tyrannosaurus est pas mieux équipée khan
ali gator par exemple et là vous avez
d'autres dinosaures théropodes il ya
certainement la lauze aux russes dans le
tas mais voyez il n'est pas mieux
équipés que qu'un crocodiliens moderne
et vous vous rappelez dans jurassic park
2 on à robert burke qui nous dit
tyrannosaurus à la plus grande cavité
olfactives toute proportion confondues à
part le vautour à tête rouge donc le
vautour qui suggère du coup encore une
fois que tyrannosaurus était charognards
cette courbe vous montre qu' il était
enfin en tout cas cette courbe suggère
que basé sur ce caractère
tyrannosaurus n'a pas plus l'air
charognards khan ali gator donc pas
charognards du tout en réalité il
pouvait sentir loin mais ça ne fait pas
forcément de lui un charognard donc ça
déjà vous voyez c'est un premier truc
qu'on peut faire justement avec la paléo
neurologie c'est tester des hypothèses
des connaissances qui semble acquise
comme ça et en particulier ce débat sur
entre prédateurs ou charognards voyez ça
c'est un débat qui existe dans la
littérature depuis au moins 30 ans et la
paléo neurologie permet d'apporter de
l'eau à ce moulin ça permet d'alimenter
ce débat et vous allez voir on va y
revenir constamment pendant toute cette
présentation sur ce débat charognards
prédateurs alors on a établi que le
tyrannosaurus dans cette situation se
trouve alan grant maintenant
même s'il peut pas vous voir il peut de
toute façon vous renifler bon maintenant
la grande question c'est est-ce que le
tyrannosaurus est réellement pas capable
de voir les trucs qui bougent pas est-ce
que sa vision est réellement basé sur le
mouvement je ne vais surprendre personne
en vous disant que
on sait pas on sait pas c'est une
hypothèse qui d'après ce que j'ai
compris a été mise sur la table alors
une hypothèse j'appelle ça une hypothèse
mais en réalité ça avait surtout il en
avait surtout besoin pour le scénario 1
que les choses soient claires c'est
c'est autant une hypothèse que un truc
balancer comme ça entre la poire et le
fromage est une hypothèse mais disons
que ça a été mis sur la table déjà à des
fins scénaristique mais aussi basée sur
le fait apparemment c'est ce que j'ai
entendu dire que le cerveau de
tyrannosaurus ressemblerait au cerveau
d'une grenouille et que les grenouilles
enfin les grenouilles prédatrice ont une
vision basée sur le mouvement
ce qui n'est pas vrai de toute façon
c'est elle voit mieux les trucs qui
bougent mais ça veut pas dire qu'elle ne
voit pas les trucs qui bougent pas
c'est à peu près tous les prédateurs
d'ailleurs qui sont câblées comme ça ils
voient vachement bien les trucs qui
bouillent mais en tout cas tyrannosaurus
n'y a pas de raison de penser qu'il
était comme ça son cerveau de toute
façon ne ressemble pas à celui d'une
grenouille s'il fallait comparer le
cerveau d'un tyrannosaurus un animal
moderne ce serait celui d'un crocodile
ou d'un alligator on va voir ça un petit
peu plus tard
tyrannosaurus n'a donc pas le cerveau
d'une grenouille il n'y a pas de raison
de penser qu'il avait donc un câblage
sensorielle similaire à celui d'une
grenouille ceci étant dit
les dinosaures de jurassic park sont
essentiellement des grenouilles je le
rappelle génétiquement parlant ils sont
ils tiennent plus de la grenouille que
du dinosaure c'est pas ce sont des
grenouilles qui ressemble à des
dinosaures mais bon je m'égare revenons
à la science la vraie la bm qu'est ce
que pouvait voir que voyaient
tyrannosaurus au final alors déjà je
vais être d'accord avec alan grant dans
cette scène le tyrannosaure ne te voit
pas parce que là regardez où ils sont
positionnés ils sont juste en dessous du
museau de tyrannosaurus est en dessous
du museau de tyrannosaurus il devait y
avoir ce qu'on appelle un énorme angle
mort
parce que quand on a des gros yeux en
haut du crâne comme ça et un énorme
museau justice y est bien ici vous avez
un angle mort donc là là où se trouve
alan grant maintenant la seule chance
que tyrannosaurus puisse le détecter ces
avec son avec son museau c'est en le
touchant éventuellement ou en le
reniflant mais il n'y a aucune chance
qu'il le voie parce que là il est en
plein dans l'angle mort du museau le
museau cache la vue en fait donc
effectivement il ne te verra pas si tu
ne bouges pas parce que tu es dans son
angle mort bon par contre il suffit
qu'ils tournent la tête était foutu mais
voilà et après c'est effectivement très
connu que tyrannosaurus avait une vision
binoculaire quand vous n'êtes pas dans
son angle mort évidemment tyrannosaurus
avait une vision binoculaire j'ai pas
vraiment besoin de citer de sources pour
ça il suffit de regarder le crâne d'un
tyrannosaurus un regard des crânes de
tyrannosaurus ici vous avez les orbites
les orbites
pointe directement vers vous comme sur
un crâne de babouins si vous regardez un
crâne de babouins vous avez exactement
la même chose qu'on les orbites marne où
un crâne humain évidemment les orbites
sont pointés directement tout droit donc
ça veut dire que les deux champs de
vision au delà de ce point mort de cet
angle mort devant le musée se
chevauchent s qui donnait à
tyrannosaurus une vision binoculaire la
capacité de voir les objets en trois
dimensions ce qui est relativement rare
dans le règne animal pour c'est
suffisamment rare pour être souligné et
évidemment ça se retrouve beaucoup chez
les carnivores notamment les félidés les
félidés ont un pareil une vision assez
binoculaire ceci étant dit les primates
aussi et ils sont pas spécialement
carnivore à paarl apport homo sapiens
qui est omnivore attendant ce carnivore
les primates de manière générale sont
pas connus pour leur quart niveau riz de
temps en temps il se hisse autorise un
petit peu de viande mais c'est pas le
gros de leur régime alimentaire donc la
vision binoculaire ça a été utilisé
comme argument en faveur de
tyrannosaurus
prédateur mais
c'est pas je veux dire c'est pas assez
pas à 100% quoi c'est loin d'être un 100
% il ya plein de raisons pour avoir une
vision binoculaire notamment la nocturne
alité les le fait de vivre dans un
environnement avec peu de lumière
ça favorise le fait d'être nocturne par
exemple les serpents qui vivent qu'ils
sont qui sont fuis soeurs qui vivent
dans les galeries ils ont une vision
plus binoculaire que les serpents qui
vivent à la surface parce que dans un
environnement de peu de lumière en fait
avoir une vision binoculaire bassa
pointe tout simplement deux fois plus de
cellules visuelles dans une même
direction donc vous avez deux fois plus
de récepteurs capables de respecter le
peu de lumière qui a plutôt que d'avoir
qu'un soleil de chaque côté qui captent
50 % de ce qui se passe vous avez deux
yeux et vous captez 100 % de ce qui se
passe je je simplifie évidemment mais
vous voyez l'idée avoir une vision
binoculaire ça vous permet de voir mieux
dans le noir du coup et ça s'est vu par
exemple chez les mammifères la fameuse
transition dont on a parlé celle été
rapide la dernière fois la fameuse
transition depuis un
qui s'appelle le goulet d'étranglement
nocturne on voit aussi ça une
convergence des orbites chez les
mammifères mésozoïque qui conduit à une
plus grande vision binoculaire ce qui
est une adaptation à la vie en milieu
obscures donc ça pourrait suggérer
effectivement que tyrannosaurus et est
un animal nocturne pourquoi pas ou en
tout cas qu'ils vivent est qui et qui
chassés ou chercher des charognes
essentiellement au crépuscule je vois
pas trop le principe de honnêtement de
chercher des charognes plus au
crépuscule que n'importe quand dans la
journée donc évidemment ça pointerait
plutôt vers un chasseur crépusculaire
ce qu'il irait de pair d'ailleurs avec
le sens de l'odorat développer puisque
ne pouvant pas autant se fier à ses yeux
qu'un animal dit urnes le tyrannosaure
suffirait à son odorat un peu encore une
fois comme chez les mammifères à la
transition du à la transition de la
nocturne alité
ceci étant dit
le meilleur moyen encore de reconstruire
les capacités visuelles d'un animal
c'est de trouver son anneau sclérotique
donc la noce sclérotique c7 ce sont ces
plaques qui s'alignent autour de la
pupille ce sont des plaques osseuses qui
s'alignent autour de la pupille qu'on
retrouve chez les reptiles moderne et
chez les oiseaux par exemple est le
mieux en fait pour reconstruire la forme
de l'oeil et donc le régime du rpt nous
ne tuerons d'un animal est bien c'est
d'avoir ces anneaux sclérotique de
préserver le problème
et qu'on les a pas pour tyrannosaurus on
les a pour gorgodze rue on les a pour
gorgon au russe est encore gorgo horus
juvénile donc gorgue autorise juvénile
vous voyez il a un oeil relativement
gros par rapport à son crâne mais c'est
un juvénile donc c'est normal qu'ils
aient un oeil plus gros par rapport à
son crâne puisque c'est le cas chez
absolument tous les juvéniles de tous
les tétrapodes donc on suppose que quand
il était adulte l'oeil devenait plus
petit mais bon c'est de toute façon
c'est gorgon au russe s'est pas
tyrannosaurus je veux dire c'est pas la
même espèce c'est même pas le même genre
donc on a pas d'anneau sclérotique pour
tyrannosaurus où les tyrannosaures ine
donc ces procès plus proches cousins
donc il faut sortir des tyrannosauridés
enfin on n'a pas démocratique pour les
adultes donc il faut sortir des
tyrannosauridés est allé voir dans les
tyrannosauridés voir les tyrannosaures
aux ide et donc ce qu'ils alertent ce
qui a l'air d'en sortir c'est que
généralement les tyrannosaures aux ide
ont un anneau sclérotique qui indique à
un oeil de dimensions relativement petit
donc possiblement des animaux qui sont
dits l'urne puisque plus votre oeil et
petits - il capte de lumière ce qui est
une protection en finale pour pas
absorbé trop de lumière est juste
devenir aveugle quoi al'inverse les
animaux nocturnes eux ont besoin de gros
yeux pour capter plus de lumière par
exemple les tarsier dont on avait parlé
la dernière fois donc donc on a cette
tendance généralement à avoir un oeil
plus gros chez les espèces nocturnes les
plus petits chez les espèces dur il
semblerait que les tyrannosaures aux ide
est plutôt étaient des animaux avec des
anneaux sclérotique indicatif d'espèces
dit youm ceci étant dit y'a jamais
aucune étude qui a été fait là dessus
donc là je suis vraiment en train de
spéculer dans le vide je nage dans le
vide littéralement
on verra le jour où on aura un anneau
sclérotique de tyrannosaurus mais si il
s'avère être petit donc indiquer un
petit oeil ce serait en contradiction
directe avec ce que je viens de vous
dire au dessus ce sont des choses qui
arrivent et vous allez voir qu'on n'est
pas à la première ni à la dernière des
contradictions quand il s'agit du
registre fossile
et de la paléo neurologiques
tyrannosaurus
puisque par exemple si on regarde le
moulage endocriniens donc vous avez ici
tyrannosaurus ans aux structures minus
au milieu donc 1
cm mais même famille que galim us and/or
ornitho mimose or die nonick us fameux
raptor devant l'éternel et archaeopteryx
le premier le tout premier oiseau vous
voyez que l'on voit bien déjà là les
changements de forme du cerveau les cra
ne sont pas à l'échelle la barre
d'échelle et indiqué là donc ça vous
indique les différences relative de saïx
de taille pardon petit mot anglais qui
s'est glissée dans ma phrase vous avez
les différences relative de taille donc
les cerveaux sont pas à l'échelle mais
ce qu'il ya d'important en fait c'est de
regarder ce qu'on appelle le lobe
optique ou le colis culv la dernière
fois je l'avais appelé le colis qu
l'optique donc le colis qu'une optique
c'est un petit goût du cerveau qui
évidemment relié à tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est géré les influx nerveux
en provenance des des orbites donc entre
les signaux visuels de manière générale
et donc ses lobes optiques chez les
oiseaux au lieu d'être situé au sommet
du crâne comme chez tout le monde les
oiseaux ont décidé que maintenant les
lobes optiques allait migrer sur le côté
et donc on arrive bien à suivre cette
migration des lobes optiques
puisque chez des nonick us vous voyez
sharks et hop terry qui sont déjà
complètement migrer sur le côté comme
chez les oiseaux modernes mais chez
démonique us voyez qu'ils sont
légèrement plus haut et ses structures
minus ils sont encore légèrement plus
roche tyrannosaurus il aurait été située
à peu près par là donc vraiment en
position dorsale là où ils sont censés
être au sommet du crâne pas au sommet du
cerveau
donc c'est l'aube optique ils ont migré
vers le bas chez les oiseaux
probablement en lien avec les
adaptations au vol avec une plus grande
agilité aussi parce que si chez
démonique us et enfin chez les paras
vient de manière générale vous avez déjà
les log optique partiellement migrer ça
veut dire que déjà ils commençaient à se
passer quelque chose chez eux et ces
animaux ne volait pas encore donc il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé qui a fait
migrer les lobes optiques sur le côté et
qui les a fait gonfler aussi parce que
vous voyez que là les lobes optiques
sont vachement marqué en fait sur le
moulage en os crânien ce qui veut dire
qu'ils étaient très gros tellement gros
qu'il touchait la paroisse crânienne et
ont obligé la paroisse crânienne à
nous les cette forme alors que chez
tyrannosaurus les lobes optiques devait
être petit complètement enterré sous une
couche de ménage et d'autres tissus
protecteur pas suffisamment gros pour
laisser en fait une empreinte sur le
cerveau donc on a non seulement une
migration des lobes optiques en se
dirigeant vers les oiseaux mais en plus
on a un gonflement de ses lobes optiques
et donc tyrannosaurus
une fois qu'on a refait ses observations
on va dire tyrannosaurus il ya aussi au
niveau de la migration des lobes
optiques avant que je pars ça
tyrannosaurus au niveau de la migration
des lobes optiques il ya aussi
l'extension en fait de ce qu'on appelle
le thé l'encéphale donc ce qui pour nous
correspond aux hémisphères cérébraux les
hémisphères cérébraux s'étendent vers
l'arrière et donc c'est par les lobes
optiques
bien que encore une fois ce sont pas ce
soit discutable puisque on n'a pas les
hémisphères eux mêmes on a que le
moulage des hémisphères en question sur
l'endocrâne mais vous voyez pareil là le
sait relativement petit chez
tyrannosaurus et ça devient de plus en
plus gros au fur et à mesure qu'on se
dirige vers les oiseaux on parlera de
l'évolution du cerveau et de
l'intelligence un petit peu plus tard en
tout et pour tout on a donc
tyrannosaurus avec des lobes optiques
relativement petit des colis cully
optique relativement petit et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
chez certains oiseaux modernes notamment
les kiwis néo kiwis qui sont nocturnes
ont des lobes optiques tout petit et
donc ça encore une fois on part dans une
possibilité ça par contre ce serait
cohérent avec tyrannosaurus nocturne
ceci étant dit il est possible que la
taille relative d'ecully cully optique
chez tyrannosaurus choisi soit juste
pardon un effet de sa taille gigantesque
c'est à dire que plus les animaux sont
gros plus ils ont un gros cerveau est
comme je vous l'avais dit la dernière
fois avec les éléphants plus le cerveau
est gros plus il ya de couche
protectrice par dessus donc c'est c'est
possible qu'en fait la seule raison pour
laquelle on voit pas les colis cully
optique sur le cerveau de tyrannosaurus
c'est parce que le cerveau de
tyrannosaure us et gros en taille
absolue par entaille relative
le cerveau tirable tyrannosaurus est le
cerveau d'un gros animal donc il est
relativement gros donc il a plus de
tissus c'est juste une fonction de la
taille il a plus de tissus ménager au
tour
donc on sait pas mais en tout cas si si
on part si on part sur une comparaison
avec le kiwi on aurait un signal
cohérent avec possiblement tyrannosaurus
nocturne ça a été proposé je dis pas je
dis pas que c'est la vérité comme je
dédie il ya plein de raisons pour
lesquelles on ne pourrait ne pas voir
les coliques ulises sur la surface du
cerveau il ya un truc intéressant aussi
qui se passe dans cette région là du
cerveau donc là on zoome ici autour de
cette structure rose qui est l'oreille
interne là on voit les canots semi
circulaire de l'oreille interne et ici
on a l'équivalent de la cour de la
cochlée qui s'appelle l'ajena macula
chez les reptiles on en reparlera mais
ici on va zoom est donc sur cette région
avec cette structure en rose pour parler
du lobe flow cullers le l'opf l'oculaire
c'est normalement vous voyez ici chez
velociraptor c'est une partie du
cervelet qui passent dans l'oreille
interne vous voyez qui si vous avez
cette ce canal semi circulaire qui se
trouve là et le locle oculaire passe
littéralement à l'intérieur vous voyez
ici c'est en vue latérale là en vue
dorsale on le voit bien traversé ici le
le canal semi circulaire pour se
projeter vers l'extérieur donc le lap
l'oculaire c'est une structure du
cervelet qui est notamment qui est très
très développée chez les animaux
prédateurs
notamment parce qu'elle est parce qu
elle sert à la coordination motrice donc
elle est généralement plus développée
chez les animaux agile et elle sert
aussi à la stabilisation de la vue donc
quand un animal va suivre un point qui
bouge à l'horizon en fait il va traquer
il va le tracé se pointent à l'horizon
l'ops l'oculaire le locle oculaire du
cervelet va être va être sollicité
pendant ce moment là donc un gros locle
oculaire
c'est un signe d'un animal plutôt agile
et plus tôt
et plutôt bon pour suivre des points et
notamment ces points sont généralement
des proies en tout cas quand on parle
des animaux carnivores donc velociraptor
loyers par exemple il a un énorme l'opf
l'oculaire l'opf oculaire très
développés ce qui suggère alors
évidemment ce qui suggère si le lobe
flow cullers du cervelet lui-même
remplissait la cavité qu'on appelle loeb
flow cullers sur leur dos crâne ce qui
suggère que velociraptor avait de très
bonnes capacités d'agilité et de chasse
personne ne remettra ça en question on
est d'accord tyrannosaurus par contre
rien il n'y a rien du tout qui passe
dans son canal semi circulaire le locle
oculaire c'est cette petite cros tulle
là il ya un tout petit petit l'autre
l'oculaire tyrannosaurus
et ça du coup si encore une fois en
partant du principe que le lobe flow
cullers donc sur l'endocrâne à une
taille proportionnelle au lot flow
cullers dans le cerveau lui même ça veut
dire que tyrannosaurus il n'était pas
très agile et qu'il avait une capacité à
suivre les points à l'horizon
relativement de mauvaises voilà une
stabilisation de la vue qui était de
manière générale très mauvaise donc pas
trop capable en fait de coordonner les
mouvements de sa tête avec les
mouvements de son corps les canots semi
circulaire de l'oreille interne soro
joue aussi un rôle là dedans c'est
l'organe de l'equilibre de manière
générale les canots semi circulaire de
l'oreille interne ce tyrannosaurus ont
rien de spéciaux il ya rien de spécial
se devait elle aussi raptors n'ont plus
soyons tout à fait honnête ils ont rien
de très particulier
donc
on peut toujours les comparer mais ça
sert à rien on voit pas de différence
majeure il n'y a pas de différence
majeure donc c'est surtout le locle
oculaire là qui est intéressant est donc
si le locle oculaire de tyrannosaurus
est petit et si le lobe populaire est
une métrique est un est un proxy de
l'agilité et de la capacité à stabiliser
la vue alors tyrannosaurus rex pu et la
merde
quand il s'agissait de chasse est donc
en tout cas de chasse et de façon très
active ce qui ne me laisse du coup avec
la possibilité qu'il ait été soit
charognards soit 1 chasseurs embusqués
voilà de ce qu'on appelle un en bouche
predator donc un chasseur embusqués donc
ça n'exclut pas totalement la
possibilité qu'il ait été chasseur mais
en tout cas s'il était chasseur il était
pas capable comme un guépard de suivre
sa proie sur des sur une longue distance
pendant une chasse endiablé c'était si
c'était un chasseur c'était un chasseur
pépère ppj
ce qui est logique aussi on a une très
très grande quantité de tyrannosaurus
toutes proportions gardées c'est
l'espèce fossiles pour laquelle on a le
plus de traces de morsures
il n'existe aucune autre espèce en tout
cas à ma connaissance pour lesquelles on
est plus de traces de morsures aucunes
autres espèces de vertébrés on reste
chez les vertébrés ya pas d'autres
espèces de vertébrés pour qui on a plus
de traces de morsures que tyrannosaurus
il ya des centaines et des centaines de
fossiles qui portent des traces de
morsures qu'on peut attribuer à
tyrannosaurus ou au moins à des
tyrannosauridés
voire même tyrannosauridés donc si c'est
pas tyrannosaurus c'est un truc qui s'en
approche donc c'est vraiment un très
très bon registre fossile qui nous
montrent des traces de morsure qui nous
indique que tyrannosaurus
qui nous indique que tyrannosaurus
chasse est essentiellement des
cératopsidés d'ead rose or parce que
c'est essentiellement là qu'on retrouve
ces traces de morsures
les serres adoption les adrs or avec
tout le respect que je leur dois je
pense pas que c'était des sprinteurs
robert bakker a suggéré qu évidemment
ils pouvaient courir puisque c'est ce
que robert baker fait et dit pain chaque
fois qu'il voit un truc il vous dit
c'est est capable de courir donc robert
baker a évidemment suggéré qu'ils
étaient capables de courir de galoper en
l'occurrence ce qui n'est pas impossible
mais c'est surtout des animaux qui sont
connus pour à s'être déplacés en groupe
pour être relativement gros relativement
lourd les ceratops hier en particulier
on sait c'est énorme cornée et toutes
ces systèmes de protection qui suggère
quand même que la course ce n'était pas
exactement la priorité à il allait
plutôt y aller à la dissuasion à grands
coups de à grand coude est trop abîmé
cornes fait gaffe
donc l'heure si c'était ça suggère quand
même que leur système de défense était
quand même plus dans la dans la
confrontation
même s'il n'y avait pas combat mais il
était quand même plus dans la
confrontation que dans la fuite
c'est un peu comme un hippopotame ou un
rhinocéros si vous voulez l'hippopotame
ou le rhinocéros
leur leur système de défense c'est pas
la fuite c'est quand même
essentiellement est regarde comment je
suis gros regarde comment je suis bien
équipé fais gaffe à toi tu vois
donc ont donc on n'est pas sur des
animaux qui vont particulièrement
prendre la fuite contrairement aux
velociraptor qui est donc un petit
prédateurs qui va essentiellement se
nourrir de petits vertébrés voire même
d'invertébrés de grande taille
tyrannosaurus on est face à un maquereau
prédateur un truc qui va bouffer d un
truc qui va s'attaquer finalement si on
est face à un prédateur évidemment pas
un charognard mais si on est face à un
prédateur on est face à un animal qui va
s'attaquer à d'autres animaux qui sont
relativement gros relativement lourd et
qui vont pas opté pour la course la
fuite comme système de défense donc
est-ce que tyrannosaurus a réellement
besoin d'être agile rapide et d'avoir
une vision stabilisé du tonnerre
je ne pense pas je ne pense pas donc ça
donc la possibilité que tyrannosaures et
était un chasseur embusqués n'est
absolument pas exclue on ne peut pas
l'exclure en tout cas avec les preuves
qu'on a de vendre
alan grant hill et donc face à 100
tyrannosaures et le tyrannosaure peut le
sentir ne peux pas le voir parce qu'il
est dans son angle mort mais bon comme
j'ai dit il suffit de tourner un peu la
tête et il le verra alan grant a aussi
ce problème qu'il respire et quand on
respire on produit du jeu des sons et
cesson et bien tyrannosaure peut les
entendre tyrannosaurus peut les entendre
puisqu'il possède une oreille interne
comme tous les vertébrés et comme la
plupart des dinosaures vous voyez ici
vous avez
alors vous avez des dinosaures mais pas
que vous avez même des terreaux zor et
vous avez même des archosaures
ancestraux tous les dinosaures en tout
cas que vous voyez en bas par exemple on
ce que l'on appelle une la jna maculata
oulhaj la macula dont je crois que c'est
l'agenais macula bref ils ont une
cochlée l'équivalent de la cochlée chez
les mammifères alors elle est pas
enroulés c'est juste une petite
languette d'où son nom la jna ça
ressemble à une langue
c'est juste une petite languette
attaché à l'oreille interne et qui prend
le rôle qu'ils jouent la fonction de
coquelets c'est l'organe de l'audition
et on retrouve ça chez les oiseaux aussi
comme vous pouvez le voir à cet endroit
là
et cette la jeune à elle est
relativement longue chez tyrannosaurus
bon vous voyez que à peu près tous les
dinosaures ont la même là je n'allais
relativement longue elle est allée et
tyrannosaurus en fait était pas spéciale
de ce point de vue là voyez que la dent
ce graphe en fait ce qui est intéressant
à regarder
c'est s'est du coup la longueur de la
jna et la longueur de la laj nash et
tous les dinosaures
comparé aux autres reptiles
chez tous les dinosaures et chez les
crocodiliens d'ailleurs elle est à peu
près similaire donc que ce soit les
oiseaux les crocodiliens où les
dinosaures des dinosaures non aviens
j'entends donc si on prend la longueur
de la jna comme une référence
delà de la capacité auditive des
tyrannosaures les tyrannosaures
entendait la même chose qu'à peu près
tout ce beau monde à savoir
essentiellement des basses fréquences
c'est ce que sont le plus capable
d'entendre les animaux qui ne sont pas
des mammifères les mammifères sont les
spécialistes haute fréquence du règne
animal même si vous avez les éléphants
et les humains qui entendent les très
basses fréquences
globalement le seul endroit où vous
allez rencontrer des spécialistes haute
fréquence ça va être surtout chez les
mammifères mais les oiseaux les
dinosaures les crocodiles apparemment
ils entendent quand même mieux les
basses fréquences donc il vous entendre
à respirer parce que respirent à la
respiration c'est essentiellement à sont
de relativement bas l'offre basses
fréquences et un son relativement grave
ceci étant dit il est intéressant de
noter que tyrannosaurus comme les
crocodiles ici où les oiseaux là il
appartient à ce grand cloud qui est ici
mis en bleu il avait eu une la jna
relativement développée relativement
longue et ce qui indique qu' il était
capable d'entendre certaines choses et
notamment les chercheurs qui ont fait ce
graphe et cette étude ici ont émis
l'hypothèse que la longueur de la jna
était directement reliée à la capacité
de communication parce qu'évidemment
vous n'allez pas produire des sons vous
ne pouvez pas entendre donc la longueur
de la cochlée ou de la jna la longueur
de la cochlée on va dire la cochlée
parce que c'est trop compliqué de dire
la jna ça m'énerve la longueur de la
cochlée chez les oiseaux et chez les
crocodiliens elle est donc directement
relié à la capacité de communication
capacités de communication qui est
surtout mis en avant pendant les phases
de communication entre même année entre
animaux d'un même groupe social ce qui a
surtout lieu avec les petits en réalité
puisque c'est puisque les principales
relations sociales tissés durant la vie
d'un animal sont surtout avec le lait
petit en tout cas dans le cas des
oiseaux il ya vous avez 7 ce phénomène
de soins parentaux
qui nécessite une communication entre
adultes et juvéniles donc c'est donc ce
qui est intéressant c'est que
apparemment
que ce soit depuis les crocodiliens
jusqu aux oiseaux on a une la jna une
coquelet qui est relativement développée
relativement longue c'est ce qu'on
voyait ici là les crocodiliens
les crocodiliens non on les voit pas les
crocodiliens mais vous avez ici les
ptérosaures voyez depuis les ptérosaures
en fait depuis l'ancêtre commun avec les
ptérosaures avait même déjà avec le parc
arias qui est encore plus ancien que
l'ancêtre avec les crocodiles vous avez
vous avez une la jna qui est
relativement longue ce qui implique du
cou qui avait une certaine quantité de
communication possibles et ça ça répond
à la question mais qu'est ce qui fait
qu'elles sont ils produisaient les
dinosaures bas on sait pas quels sont
ils produisaient mais on sait qu'ils
étaient capables d'entendre les basses
fréquences donc plutôt des sons graves
et on sait qu'ils étaient capables de
communiquer en tout cas d'entendre des
sons qui correspondent à ce qu'on
appellerait nous des communications donc
est-ce que déjà ils produisaient des
sons bah oui apparemment oui sinon il
n'y a pas d'intérêt à pouvoir les
entendre c'est sont donc est ce qu'ils
produisaient des sons oui est-ce qu'ils
étaient capables de grenier on le saura
jamais
est-ce qu'il est est ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire exactement comme les oiseaux
d'aujourd'hui probablement pas parce que
les oiseaux d'aujourd'hui ont ce qu'on
appelle un syrinx donc qui est un organe
vocal extrêmement spécialisé pour
l'instant on n'en a jamais retrouvé de
trace en dehors que chez les oiseaux
donc donc on ne sait pas si les
théropodes en avait un et jusqu'à preuve
du contraire ils n'en avaient pas les
théropodes non aviens je l'entend
évidemment donc est-ce que tyrannosaurus
était capable de communiquer avec ses
congénères la réponse est oui
probablement
s'il communiquait c'était avec des sons
probablement basses fréquences ce qui
est quand même relativement cohérent
avec ses dimensions parce que plus on
est gros plus on a des grosses plus on a
un gros organe vocal et plus on a tapant
qui est très très grand 1 est donc un
tympan très grand et très sensible du
coût de pas juste là c'est de la
physique pure et dure en fait c'est un
tympan très grand et meilleur à entendre
des basses fréquences est un organe
vocal très grand et meilleur à produire
des basses fréquences donc globalement
si tyrannosaure produisait des sons et
on pense que c'est le cas basé sur cette
étude il produisait des sont basses
fréquences
rien n'est exclu
évidemment puisque comme j'ai dit on n'a
pas de trace de présence ou d'absence de
syrinx en absence de preuves on va
plutôt considéré qu'il avait pas de
syrinx mais rien n'est exclu on sait que
les crocodiles produisent des 100 basses
fréquences très gutturaux on va dire les
oiseaux aussi sont capables de produire
des sons de cette façon notamment les
oiseaux qui ne chante pas on va surtout
regarder d'ailleurs parce que c'est bien
joli de dire que les que les dinosaures
faisait pipi ou et puis chanter mais en
réalité il ya que les oiseaux qui
chantent
c'est qu'on appelle lé passé reform
qu'ils sont capables de faire ça si vous
regardez les anaty forme par exemple les
poules ou si vous regardez les paléo
guinée at c'est à dire les autruches et
les haineux etc eux ils chantent pas
enfin si un cox ça fout le bordel mais
c'est pas assez déjà on n'est pas sûr
puppy pipiou ouais on est plutôt sur
cocorico et coincoin et pour les
autruches pas grand chose donc ils sont
capables de produire des sons mes cd
sont beaucoup moins élaborées que les
champs très diversifiés dépasser les
formes donc ça il faut bien faut bien
par contre exclure le fait qu'il
chantait ça je pense que c'est même pas
jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est je
pense qu'on s'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est très spécifique n'est pas
dépasser les formes le chant le
grognement donc le rugissement la queue
tyrannosaure pousse de façon iconique
dans jurassic park ça c'est un truc de
lyon enfin deux du genre pantera au sein
des félidés au sein des mammifères donc
ça c'est quasiment sûr que c'est non
dans ce documentaire préhistorique
planète on voit deux tyrannosaurus un
mâle et une femelle se rencontrer et
s'étirera on nous dit la voix nous dit
tyrannosaurus avait une phase
extrêmement sensible donc la peau sur le
museau de tyrannosaurus était
extrêmement sensible vous voyez ici ses
écailles aligner qu'on suppose être des
récepteurs sensoriels on va dire on nous
le dit pas mais on accepte assez
facilement de ce on s'autorise soi même
de se dire que ce sont des récepteurs
sensoriels et est donc on les voit se
toucher la face caressait délicatement
la face comme ça et on nous dit la voix
nous racontera ils ont ils ont un museau
très très sensible et c'est comme ça
qu'il communique etc etc
là ça fait partie des choses qui m'ont
embêté dans préhistorique planète on va
pas se le cacher tyrannosaurus rex la
sensibilité de la face et enfin
l'hypothèse de tyrannosaurus rex avec
une sensibilité de la face exacerbé est
très fortement contrasté avec le
registre fossile deux des nombreuses au
maxillaire dentaires et des nombreux
crâne qu'on a retrouvé de tyrannosaurus
qui nous indique qu'il avait des traces
de morsures absolument partout c'est
plus de la moitié des fossiles qu'on a
provenant du museau de tyrannosaurus rex
donc dans maxillaire près maxillaire
nasal et dentaires c'est plus de la
moitié de ces ossements
donc c'est plus ce qui représente
plusieurs centaines
d'ossements plusieurs centaines de
fragments de crâne qui portent des
traces de morsures qu'on suppose avec
raison avoir été fait par d'autres
membres de la même espèce donc d'autres
membres des tyrannosauridés là en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas que
tyrannosaurus rex seller tyrannosauridés
angers les tyrannosaures inné pardon en
général donc c'est pas que tyrannosaurus
rex mais bon il n'y a pas de raison pour
le coup il n'y a pas de raison de penser
que tyrannosaurus rex était différent
des autres tyrannosauridés
tyrannosauridés puisqu'on retrouve les
mêmes traces sur les sur les eaux de
tyrannosaurus rex donc disons qu on a
beaucoup moins ça chez tyrannosaurus rex
est beaucoup plus ça donc une phase qui
devait être largement sic un couvert de
cicatrices et de et de déformations dues
à des morsures qui ont été faites par
des congénères
pour la simple et bonne raison que c'est
comme ça que nos tyrannosauridés
communiqué semblerait-il c'est comme ça
qu'il se disait bonjour qu'il disait
c'est moi qui domine qui te disais non
ça c'est ma femelle ou ça c'est mon mal
parce que je rappelle que les femelles
sont plus grosses que les mâles chez
tyrannosaurus donc il est possible que
ce soit les femelles qui ce soit qui se
sont battus pour mal même si on n'a pas
de preuves évidemment mais c'est une
possibilité dans la mesure où les
femelles sont plus grosses que les mâles
on va pas pourquoi ce serait les mâles
qui se seraient battus entre eux et quel
intérêt les femelles d'être plus grosse
si c'est pas elle justement qui se
battent de break
donc il ya c'était une forme de
communication sociale qu'on appelle le
faith biting ça n'a pas de nom français
c'est le faith biting morsure morsure du
visage qui existent aussi chez d'autres
animaux comme les loups par exemple mais
qui existe aussi chez les warrants et
chez plat de vertébrés donc ce n'est pas
spécial c'est pas spécial à
tyrannosaurus rex mais c'est par contre
l'abondance de ces morsures est assez
est assez ouf en fait chez les
tyrannosauridés comparable à ce qu'on
voit notamment chez les crocodiles donc
on a beaucoup aussi de morsures social
chez les crocodiles toujours pareil pour
dire c'est moi le plus fort c'est moi le
match donc ça c'est ça c'est très
intéressant de voir justement ce
contraste entre ce qui a été dit dans ce
documentaire et les traces fossiles
qu'on a alors d'où elle vient cette idée
de la sensibilité de la face accrue chez
un chai des tyrannosauridés ça vient en
fait de ces petites roues qu'on voit sur
le museau voyez vous reconnaissez que
ses tricks
et voyez que tricks comme tous les
tyrannosaurus rex elle a des petits
trous sur le visage alors là il ya des
petits trous mais c'est une pathologie
mais là ces petits trous là vous voyez
au dessus de la lèvre ou là où la lèvre
se serait situé on va dire tous ces
petits trous là ce sont des faux ramène
sensitif enfin neurosensorielle ce qui a
décrit de là-bas ce sont des faux ramène
neurosensorielle et vasculaire donc il y
avait du nerf et de la haie du vaisseau
sanguin qui passait par ces trous et on
retrouve la même chose voyez chez les
crocodiles des crocodiles ont aussi la
face recouverte de petits trous comme ça
et chez les crocodiles on sait que ces
trous sont remplies de récepteurs qu'on
appelle les dom prêcheur receptor les
récepteurs de pression en forme de dôme
qui capte en fait les différences de
pression à l'intérieur de l'eau quand il
chasse avec leurs yeux sortant pour ça
c'est un alligator ce n'est pas un
crocodile mais c'est la même chose vous
avez les yeux qui sortent de l'eau 1 et
vous avez le nez qui est planté dans
l'eau et dans l'eau en fait ça va ces
récepteurs en forme de dôme vont capter
les différences de pression
de l'eau et donc capté l'éventuelle
présence de proie donc ça veut pas dire
que tyrannosaurus était ce aquatique et
qu'il chassait avec le nez dans l'eau
mais en tout cas ça suggère que
tyrannosaurus avait en tout cas des
récepteurs au moins similaire à celui
des crocodiles en tout cas c'est ce que
les gens ont proposé par le passé ce
qu'on a fait avec mon étudiant mon
étudiant florian bouabdellah ma collègue
émilie les senneurs c'est qu'on a étudié
du coup à tyrannosaurus un scan de
tyrannosaurus celui de sioux pour
essayer de tester cette hypothèse parce
qu'il y avait un truc qui nous
dérangeait dans cette hypothèse c'est
que quand vous cherchez bien en réalité
des petites roues comme ça on n'en
trouve pas que chez les crocodiles on en
trouve aussi à moindre mesure chez les
warrants qui n'ont pas une sensibilité
de la face exacerbé comme les crocodiles
et on les trouve même chez les synapses
id d'ailleurs ces mêmes surtout pour ça
que quand on est parti dans la direction
de remettre en question ce qui était
jusqu'à présent du savoir communément
admis la sensibilité de la phase de
tyrannosaurus il ya personne qui avait
vraiment remis ça en question mais c'est
quand moi j'ai noté que énorme et attend
là il ya plein de trous aussi sur la
face de messine apside là pourquoi
voilà et on en a parlé la dernière fois
dans la vidéo sur la paléo neurologie je
vous avais dit les gens les gens
supposer que c'était pour les moustaches
bon en fait non mais c'est pas pour les
moustaches mais n'empêche qu'ils ont
plein de petits trous aussi sur la face
est en fait tous les lézards et tous les
tous les reptiles de manière générale on
de tels petits trous dans la face et y
compris ceux qui n'ont pas de
sensibilité particulière de la face donc
il ya un problème il ya un problème avec
cette hypothèse que le tyrannosaurus rex
avait une phase extrêmement sensible
donc ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
utilisé le scan donc de sioux et on a on
a extrait on va dire de façon numérique
les canaux qui connecte tous ces trous
au nerf trijumeau puisque le nerf qui
innerve la face c'est le nerf trijumeau
il ya aussi des vaisseaux sanguins qui
passent par là mais évidemment c'est pas
ça qui nous intéresse nous ce qui va
nous intéresser les nerfs c'est la
sensibilité et donc quand on regarde ces
canaux on constate effectivement une
complexité non négligeable de ces canaux
notamment ici cela en bleu vous voyez
celui en bleu qui passe dans le
maxillaire est très très complexe très
très ramifié vous avez une branche
principale qui on dirait de la pluie
finalement qui répandent et d'autres
plus petites branches jusqu'au dessus de
la lèvre donc au dessus de la lèvre
c'est là qu'on voit les autres
tous ces faux ramène tous ces petits
trous que vous que je vous ai montré sur
la photo là au dessus de la lèvre c'est
dans ce canal qu'ils vont en fait ils
remontent jusqu'à ce canal principal et
pouf qui ramène l'influx nerveux
jusqu'au crâne neutre est le nerf
trijumeau il est très intéressant parce
que c'est un air qui est purement
sensitif sauf quelques exceptions c'est
un air qui est purement sensitif donc
ils ramènent juste là ça c'est vraiment
juste la sensibilité de la face que vous
regardez quand vous regardez ce nerf là
il va aussi dans le pré maxillaire ici
il va dans le sens nasal et il va dans
l'os dentaire dont claude dentaire
pareil vous avez des trous aligné au
dessus de la lèvre et ses nerfs qui
remonte ensuite vers un canal principal
qui va remonter à l'arrière de la
mâchoire jusque dans le servent donc ces
1ères qui est à l'air extrêmement
complexe vu comme ça très complexe
notamment comparé à un oiseau voyez que
l'oiseau doivent est une branche là qui
part par là c'est la branche ophtalmique
vous n'avez même pas de branches
maxillaire ici c'est le branchant bleus
il n'y a même pas de branches maxillaire
pour une raison très simple c'est que la
branche branche ophtalmique ses serres
qui c'est celle qui énerve le lot spray
maxillaire est en fait le bec des
oiseaux est purement fait de loos près
maxillaire et le maxillaire est tout
petit donc cette branche maxillaire ici
en bleu vu que l'os maxillaire est lui
même réduit la branche maxillaire de
l'unr est elle même réduite donc
tyrannosaurus même si les plus proches
parents avec les oiseaux qu'avec le
crocodile il n'a pas du tout une
conformation des nerfs qui est similaire
à celle des oiseaux mais beaucoup plus à
celle bad unes des autres dinosaures
théropodes vous voyez ici lol le nerf
extrêmement complexe d autres dinosaures
théropodes spinosaurus et néo venator
mais surtout une complexité qui est
similaire à celle des crocodiles alors
la couleur est pas la même mais là vous
voyez en bleu ici c'est le même nerfs
que le nerf en envers ici vous voyez
cette complexité elle est assez
similaire à celle des crocodiles
et du coup on serait tenter de confirmer
bien oui mais oui
on aurait envie de dire mais oui du coup
tyrannosaurus avait effectivement une
grande sensibilité de la face même si
c'est contradictoire avec le fait qu'il
se mordait copieusement la tronche parce
que si vous avez une grande sensibilité
de la face et que vous vous mordez
copieusement la tronche vous risquez les
infections de votre mère vous risquez la
douleur vous risquez beaucoup de choses
bon ceci dit avoir une grande
sensibilité de la masse de la face
pardon et de se mordre copieusement la
figure
encore une fois si on est sur du
signalement social bombes à eau - vous
comprenez bien ce qui se passe voilà
avant moi au moins y'a pas de doute sur
ce qui est en train de se passer sur
votre tronche vous êtes en train de vous
faire dominer c'est possible c'est
possible ceci étant dit quand on regarde
du coup les crocodiles et qu'on les
compare à d'autres dinosaures et à
tyrannosaurus rex parce que évidemment
le nerf trijumeau n'a pas été regardé
que chez tyrannosaurus rex en fait vous
voyez les crocodiles ils ont surtout des
récepteurs au sommet du museau sur le
pré maxillaire voyez c'est ça les fameux
dômes receptor dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure ces récepteurs sont sous
pseudo distribués au sommet du museau au
bout du museau vraiment et au bout du
museau d'un tyrannosaurus enfin et au
bout du museau des espèces aquatiques
vous voyez il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de terminaisons nerveuses donc
ici par exemple vous avez un crocodile
ici vous avez ces alsc à raptor donc le
ce fameux dinosaures drôme et aux
proches des drôme et aux orres qui
ressemblait à un signe et qu'on suppose
être semi aquatique vous avez ici
spinosaurus pareil vous voyez la
quantité de terminaisons nerveuses sur
le pré mais sur le maxillaire ici est
loin d'être comparable à ce qui se passe
au niveau du prêt vaxillaire beaucoup de
terminaisons nerveuses sur le prix maxi
d'air ici vous avez un pli aux orres pas
du tout un dinosaure mais un reptile
marin du mésozoïque mais pareil vous
avez une condition qui est extrêmement
similaires voyez au crocodile beaucoup
de terminaisons nerveuses dans le pré
maxillaire certainement pour atteindre
des récepteurs comparables à ceux des
crocodiles et à côté de ça vous avez
tyrannosaurus quand on regarde ce qui se
passe dans son pré maxillaire ici là
vous voyez il ya très très peu de
petites ou dans son pré maxillaire et
les branches sont pas spécialement hyper
dense c'est pas comparer à ce qui se
passe voyez dans le maxillaire dans le
dentaire et dans le nasale
il n'y a pas de temps de terminaisons
nerveuses que ça qu'ils ont l'air
d'atteindre le pré maxillaire de
tyrannosaurus donc pour ce qui est
comparable au niveau du prêt maxillaire
il est plus raisonnable en tout cas
c'est ce que on a conclu florian
bouabdellah et
emilie et moi même dans notre article et
emilie a
présenté l'année dernière où je sais que
je crois que c'était l'année dernière
une conférence la society of vertebrate
paleontology où elle a étudié plus en
détail la sensibilité de la face chez
les dinosaures et où elle confirme et où
elle confirmait mais ça reste encore à
être publiées où elle confirmé que
tyrannosaurus apparemment il n'est pas
spécial il n'est pas spécial niveau
sensibilité de la face donc
donc en tout cas comparé à c'est
possible semi aquatique c'est possible
dinosaures semi-aquatique donc ce qu'on
en concluait c'est que tyrannosaure
avait pas spécialement une phase très
sensible alors pourquoi cette complexité
s'il n'avait pas une phase très sensible
puisque je le rappelle si une structure
volumineuse et complexes et fonctionne
pas mieux qu'une structure
simple est de petite taille en paléo
neurologie va falloir expliquer pourquoi
parce que je vous rappelle que la taille
et la complexité c'est la seule chose
qui nous indique un fonctionnement
accrue donc là pour expliquer
éventuellement la possibilité que
tyrannosaurus n'ai pas eu une phase si
sensible que ça
ce qui serait cohérent avec le fait
qu'ils se la mort des complètement la
face on a proposé que c'est parce que
tyrannosaurus il ad énormes racines
voyez les dents de tyrannosaurus si on
les compare souvent à des bananes voyez
c'est des dents qui sont comac
vava 25 cm sauf que les 25 cm en fait il
ya 20 cm de racine il ya que ça qui
dépasse les que 10 cm qui dépasse et il
ya 15 20 cm de racine et donc ses
racines faut qu'ils aillent quelque part
et elles vont ou bien dans le maxillaire
elle s'enfonce très profondément dans le
maxillaire et de fait ces racines ont
poussé le canal du r trijumeau vers le
haut sauf que le nerf trijumeau il doit
encore faire son boulot et avoir une
sortie au niveau de la lèvre parce que
c'est là qu'il est utile c'est là
qu'elle est utile la sensibilité c'est
au niveau des lèvres donc pour que la
pour finalement que ce nerf ce canal du
nerf trijumeau puisse encore atteindre
le la marge inférieure du maxillaire où
la marge supérieure du dentaire et bien
il a fallu allonger le les petits canaux
qui se dirigent vers les foramen supra
la bio ces petites roues qu'on voit sur
la lèvre et à l'allongement en fait de
ces canaux créé et la possible fusion de
ces canaux les uns avec les autres qui
peut arriver pendant la vie pendant leur
modélisation du canteleu quand l'os
finalement se modifie
se répare et c'est assez il va y avoir
des fusions qui vont avoir lieu entre
les canaux qu'ils ont pas forcément
fonctionnellement utiles mais elles sont
là et tout ça ça va créer un faux
semblants de complexité en fait ça va
créer un semblant de complexité qui n'a
pas de fonctions particulières que
d'amener finalement le nerf là où il est
censé être utile à partir d'une position
beaucoup trop éloigné à cause de la
présence de ses racines gigantesque donc
ce serait en fait tout ce qu'on serait
en train de regarder ce serait juste un
effet secondaire de la cette complexité
en fait ne serait qu'un effet secondaire
de la présence de racines très profondes
chez tyrannosaurus rex de racines
dentaires très profonde chez
tyrannosaurus rex donc ce qu'on voit
très bien ici sur ce scan en rouge c'est
la racine de tirades d'une banque
tyrannosaurus rex qui a poussé le canal
vert par là et donc après vous avez le
canal qui doit redescendre jusqu'ici
pour aller faire son boulot là où il est
utile et pareil pour le canal dentaire
ici en verre qui a été poussé par la
racine de cette danse vers le bas et qui
maintenant on doit envoyer une branche
jusque là haut pour aller innervé la
zone qui est réellement utile la zone
labial donc ça c'est l'hypothèse qu'on a
proposé pour expliquer pour essayer de
rendre compte du fait que le canal de
tyrannosaurus rex finalement il n'est
pas comparable même s'il est
relativement il allait relativement
complexe il n'est pas comparable à celui
des crocodiles dont il n'y a pas une
sensibilité de la phase qui a l'air si a
cru que ça et en même temps vous avez
cette complexité visible
qu'il faut expliquer c'est comme ça que
nous en tout cas on l'expliquent mais
évidemment ces sujets à débats ces
sujets à caution il ya eu plein il ya
des gens qui ont fait notamment des
vidéos pas encore des articles mais au
moins des vidéos pour essayer de
proposer d'autres hypothèses on espère
que ça sortira en articles parce que moi
ça m'intéresse bon en tout cas cet
article j'ai été très content de le
faire parce que il ya enfin mon nom qui
est associé au mot tyrannosaurus rex
dans un article alors que alors qu'à la
base j'étudie pas les dinosaures du tout
donc j'étais super content et ben
j'espère que j'espère qu'il y aura plein
de discussion alors évidemment ça ça
pose la question depuis tout à l'heure
je vous parle de la zone labiales et des
lèvres donc ça pose évidemment la
question est ce que les dinosaures
avaient des lèvres ou pas est-ce que
tyrannosaurus avait des lèvres ou pas
j'avais déjà fait une vidéo sur le sujet
où justement je rappelais que dans la
saga jurassic park on a les deux on a
des dinosaures qui ont des lèvres comme
les velociraptor envoyé on ne voit pas
les dents et des dinosaures qui n'ont
pas de lèvres comme par exemple l'inde
minus ou le tyrannosaure un peu qu'ils
n'ont pas de lèvres et dont on voit les
temps les dents ne sont pas cool
recouvert par des lèvres donc ça c'est
la condition qu'on voit chez les lézards
chez les varans de komodo par exemple
une bouche fermée chez le varan de
komodo vous ne voyez rien même avec la
bouche ouverte d'ailleurs vous verrez
pas grand chose et ça c'est la condition
qu'on voit chez les crocodiles donc chez
les crocodiles on a vraiment les temps
qui sont complètement apparente et chez
les alligators vous avez un peu un mix
entre les deux avec les temps de du
dessus qui sont apparentes mais pas les
dents du dessous donc que qu'est ce qui
se passe du coucher tyrannosaurus et
chez les dinosaures en général est-ce
qu'on avait des lèvres ou est-ce qu'on
en avait pas faut savoir déjà que c'est
un débat qui intéresse pas tant que ça
les chercheurs c'est un débat qui
intéresse surtout les pannes et aux
artistes les chercheurs il s'en tape un
peu et si on leur pose la question vaut
mieux montrer les dents pour deux
raisons principales la première c'est
que du nom n'est paléontologues les
paléontologues s'avance essentiellement
avec les dents donc si sur ton sur la
représentation d'un dinosaure tu nous
montres pas les dents d'un dinosaure ou
d'autre chose a d'ailleurs
donc si sur tarbes représentation de ton
animal préhistorique tu montres pas les
dents en gros le chercheur il s'en fout
parce que tu ne montres pas ce qui est
plus intéressant de nous ce qui nous
intéresse essentiellement c'est les
dents donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
toujours les animaux en train de réussir
sur les sur les images en train de
bâiller en train de c'est parce qu'on
veut voir les dents nous en tant que
chercheur on aime bien montrer les dents
parce que c'est ça qui nous intéresse
c'est c'est là que se trouve toute la
sève de la recherche c'est sur les dents
les dents ça indique tellement de choses
sur la biologie des animaux et sur leur
relation de parenté aussi qu' on veut
voir les dents veut les montres et on
veut que les données soient visibles sur
les représentations même quand elles
sont artistiques donc ça c'est la
première raison la deuxième raison c'est
que si vous vous posez la question
est-ce qu'il faut mettre ou pas de la
viande en plus sur votre constitution le
chercheur vous répondra toujours qu'il
faut en remettre - parce que vous
travaillez à l'économie d'hypothèses
chaque structure molle donc non
fossilisés que vous rajouter à votre
votre création artistique votre
reconstruction de dinosaures par exemple
chacune de ces structures molle non
fossilisés est une hypothèse non est
stable que vous rajouter à votre votre
dessin et les hypothèses non non tu est
stable nous on n'aime pas ça les
paléontologues
il n'aime pas ça les scientifiques
n'aime pas ça de manière générale nous
on aime bien les hypothèses étaient
stables on aime bien quand il ya des
données concrètes qui sont derrière les
reconstitutions artistique et voilà m
des lèvres ou des trucs comme ça c'est
ça va à l'encontre en fait de ce
principe d'économie d'hypothèses ce
n'est pas par simone yeux voilà donc
c'est les deux raisons pour laquelle on
si vous demandez à un paléontologue
généralement le paléontologue à vous
dire non mais pas de lèvres
si c'est un mammifère tous les
mammifères ont des lèvres dont il ya pas
de soucis mais chez les reptiles la
question est très différent tous les
reptiles non pas des lèvres donc au sein
des reptiliens vous avez évidemment le
plus proche parent d des tyrannosaures
et des dinosaures non aviens en général
que sont les oiseaux donc au sein des
oiseaux vous avez vous avez bambecque
voilà donc et pas de lèvres chez les
oiseaux donc les plus proches parents
des dinosaures n'ont pas de lèvres parce
qu'ils ont à bec alors la plupart des
gens vous diront bah ouais enfin du coup
c'est pas très comparable ok on va
s'éloigner des dinosaures on va aller
voir les crocodiles donc on est toujours
au sein des archosaures mais maintenant
on est plus sur un analogue à
tyrannosaurus qu'un réel proches parents
puisque je rappelle les dinosaures non
aviens sont beaucoup plus proches
parents des oiseaux qui ne le sont des
crocodiles donc on est sur un analogue
maintenant un analogue le crocodile qui
a effectivement un canal maxillaire très
complexe mais qui n'a pas de lèvres donc
les crocodiles les alligators ils ont
pas de lèvres et là on l'a généralement
les paléo artistes vous dise oui mais
pareil c'est pas comparable parce qu'ils
sont semi aquatique et donc parce qu'ils
seraient semi-aquatique ils n'auraient
pas besoin d'avoir les dents protéger
parce que même si comme il s'est
représenté ici il passe 90% de leur
temps à glander au soleil avec la bouche
ouverte apparemment le fait d'être semi
aquatique pour les paléo artistes comme
je les dis c'est surtout une discussion
de paléo artiste je dis pas ça parce que
je méprise les paléo artistes et c'est
surtout une discussion de paléo artistes
donc
l'épaule et aux artistes vont
s'engueuler en vous disant non non non c
c aquatique ça marche pas bon bah les
temps on s'éloigne encore un petit peu
le plus le prochain proches parents des
dinosaures sur l'arbre phylogénétique
c'est les tortues baver les tortues font
partie des arts queloz oria donc mix
entre kélonia et arrco zorya donc les
prochains proches parents des dinosaures
ce sont les tortues les tortues pareil
qu'elles soient terrestres ou aquatiques
elles ont un bec elles ont pas de lèvres
et elles ont un canal sur un canal
maxillaire qui est complexe comme
tyrannosaurus comme les comme les
crocodiles
bon ça fait quand même beaucoup de
proches parents de tyrannosaurus qui
n'ont pas de lèvres je rappelle que même
au sein des dinosaures non aviens la
plus il y en a beaucoup beaucoup qui ont
un mec aussi
vous avez palaiseau vie raptor vous avez
les ornithologues aux orres vous avez
letairis dinosaures au sein des
théropodes et puis après tout les
ornithischiens basiquement avait avec
aussi
tout se passe comme si chez les arcs et
lauzon rien et notamment chez les
dinosaures parmi eux en tout cas les
archosaures parmi eux tout se passe
comme si chez les arcs et loria
dinosaures inclus et vous se voir
évoluer un bec était quand même un truc
qui arrive est très très souvent ce qui
tend à suggérer que la chose qui précède
l'évolution du bec devait pas être
très très utile et très très charnues
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle donc ce que
je vais me faire là on appelle ça le
philo genetic bracketing donc là
l'optimisation phylogénétique c'est à
dire on regarde les proches parents on
regarde ce qui se passe et si chez les
proches parents il n'y a pas de lèvres
bas c'est qu'à priori des dinosaures non
aviens n'avait pas de l'ebre et comme je
les dis tout se passe comme si
effectivement il n'avait pas de lèvres
puisque la plupart des dinosaures non
aviens vont se diriger vers l'évolution
d'un bec
alors que pendant ce temps là dans
d'autres lignes et comme l'était rapide
par exemple il n'ya jamais qu'un seul
clad chez qui un bec m 2 pardon 2 il ya
deux clad chez qui un bec a évolué les
mots notres m et les dix innovantes
les autres les autres n'ont pas de bec
donc
l'évolution d'un bec c'est quand même
produit moins souvent chez les synapses
id que chez les reptiliens
et notamment les arcs hello there donc
d'un côté je trouverais encore
raisonnable de dire ok dit métro dont
devaient peut-être avoir des lèvres de
l'autre côté ça devient très compliqué
de soutenir l'hypothèse que
tyrannosaurus avait des lèvres et chez
les reptiliens on a donc les l'epide aux
orres romoff donc les lézards et les
serpents qui ont effectivement des
lèvres comme ce varan de komodo mais là
par contre on a un canal maxillaire qui
a rien à voir avec celui de
tyrannosaurus puisque il est très simple
voyez il est linéaire est vraiment pas
compliqué du tout alors comme je les dis
ça peut être une fonction pour moi c'est
essentiellement une fonction de la
longueur des racines l'epide aux orres
n'ayant pas de racines à leurs dents ils
ont des dents qu'on appelle à crozon qui
sont qui sont nos racines et non
enracinée donc pour moi c'est une
fonction du développement de la racine
mais enfin on a quand même le fait que
les l'epide aux oraux morts sont les
seuls à avoir des lèvres et ils sont
tous descendants d'un unique ancêtres en
commun ce qui veut dire que en fait le
fait d'avoir des lèvres peut tout aussi
bien n'être qu'une synap au mans fidèle
et pi 2 euros mort c'est-à-dire un
caractère dérivés qui n'ait comme à
queue au l'epide aux aurores hérité d'un
unique ancêtres en commun donc même s'il
ya 5000 espèces de l'épi d'or au mof bah
ça ne fait jamais qu'une seule
l'occurence
l'ancêtre en commun en question ça ne
fait qu'une seule occurrence de
l'évolution des lèvres en fait les
lèvres n'ont pas évolué cinq mille fois
même s'il ya 5000 espèces de l'épi d'or
qui ont qui ont deux lézards et de
serpents qui ont des lèvres ça n'a
évolué qu'une seule fois chez leurs
ancêtres en commun
donc c'est donc vous n'avez pas un
argument force 5000 vous avez un
argument fort st c'est
donc on en est toujours au même point
est-ce qu'ils avaient des airs ou pas je
sais pas je sais pas mais c'est peu
probable en tout cas
et maintenant on attaque la dernière
partie la partie la plus intéressante on
va enfin parler du cerveau saviez vous
aviez comme projette parler du cerveau
ou dans votre votre conférence consacrée
au cerveau donc on a fait tout le
système
enfin on a déjà parlé du cerveau quand
même on a parlé du serveur de l'opf
l'oculaire on a parlé des colis qu
l'optique quand même on a abordé le
cerveau bon on a fait le système
sensoriel périphériques on a fait
les organes des sens maintenant on
termine par le cerveau le coeur de là le
coeur de la discussion le coeur du débat
qu'est ce qui se passe au niveau de ce
cerveau bon alors en fonds sont avant
tout les portes ouvertes le cerveau d'un
tyrannosaure c'est pas bien grand vous
avez ici le cerveau enfin le crâne en
transparent de ciu qui vous est
représentée ici elle est très jolie
crâne vous avez le crâne transparent de
sioux et ici vous avez en rose je vous
ai représenter le cerveau envers vous
avez les canaux dont on vient de parler
le canal maxillaire avec le nerf
trijumeau
représentés de façon ultra simplifié
parce que sinon ça bouffe de la ram mais
ici vous avez le cerveau donc de
tyrannosaurus et vous pouvez voir que
déjà par rapport au crâne là on accole
crâne et déjà par rapport au crâne le
cerveau il est pas énorme
c'est pas c'est pas un gros cerveau
c'est pas une grosse bête le cerveau
d'un tyrannosaure pour un animal de cinq
tonnes de sacs à 7 tonnes vous avez un
cerveau de 300 400 grammes donc le
basiquement un animal de la taille d'un
éléphant voire même plus gros donc un
animal de la taille d'un éléphant avec
le cerveau de la taille de celui d'un
orang outan d'un petit chimpanzé parce
que je pense et on est déjà sûr du 400
donc de la taille d'un
chimpanzé donc ça fait beaucoup de
viande pour très peu de matière
cérébrale le cerveau donc de
tyrannosaure est relativement petit par
par rapport à sa taille on aura
l'occasion d'en haut on va en reparler
dans les prochaines minutes la forme du
cerveau de tyrannosaure maintenant même
si les proches parents des oiseaux le
cerveau de tyrannosaure est très très
similaire à celui des crocodiles à
savoir qu'il est plutôt linéaire voyez
que c'est un cerveau qui est quand même
plutôt allongé comme celui d'un
crocodile alors que celui des oiseaux si
les plus globulaires
donc les oiseaux ont un cerveau
globulaires avec des hémisphères très
très développée donc d une partie la
partie qui sert à réfléchir du cerveau
des oiseaux est très développée alors
que chez tyrannosaure les hémisphères
vous voyez ils sont juste là voilà juste
où j'ai mis ma souris donc c'est
vraiment là c'est vraiment le milieu
voilà le tiers du milieu de l'endocrâne
je vous montrerai un petit peu après
qu'ils aient réellement
qui correspond réellement à la partie
qui sert à réfléchir
donc ils sont pas très développé et ce
qui de fait parce que c'est hémisphère
ne sont pas très développée ils sont
assez verticalement et de fait les le
cerveau a un aspect très linéaire très
tubulaire ce qui correspond à ce qu'on
voit chez les crocodiles un peu moins
linéaire que les crocodiles parce que
les les lobes olfactives sont pas
pédonculé chez tyrannosaurus les lobes
actifs sont directement attaché au corps
cérébrale on va dire alors que chez les
crocodiles voyez il ya cette espèce de
pédoncule qui se projette vers l'avant
cette espèce demande de file de
filaments et les lobes olfactif sont
projetés vers l'avant en fait à l'avant
de leur [ __ ] alors que chez tyrannosaure
ils sont directement attaché donc c'est
la seule différence majeure sinon le
cerveau de tyrannosaurus est très proche
de celui d'un crocodile est très proche
de manière générale de celui des autres
dinosaures c'est à dire la plupart des
dinosaures non aviens ont un cerveau
extrêmement tubulaire et on va voir que
même archéoptéryx diffère pas tant que
ça du patron de base on va dire des
dinosaures théropodes
maintenant allemagne en matière de
taille on en a déjà parlé la dernière
fois de la taille du cerveau de
tyrannosaurus donc le cerveau de
tyrannosaurus là vous voyez on a une
estimation faite par larsson et al 2000
il ya plein d'estimation de la taille du
cerveau qui a été fait de tyrannosaurus
on navigue dans les 300 400 centimètres
cubes ce qui comme je vous le disais est
à peu près équivalent à la taille du
cerveau d'un chimpanzé ou d'un fin d'un
petit chimpanzé ou d'un orang outan
enfin bref on est niveau on est à peu
près ce niveau là donc on est sur un
cerveau qui occuperait à peu près cet
espace la comparer à moi un tiers un peu
moins d'un tiers de moins car un quart
de la taille du cerveau d'al humains
pour un animal qui je le rappelle fait
la taille d'un éléphant donc les
éléphants ils ont un gros cerveau pour
leur taille je vous le rappelle le
tyrannosaure lui pas du tout
c'est aussi d'ailleurs
plutôt que parler en primates c'est
c'est carrément la taille du cerveau
d'un rhinocéros ou d'un hippopotame
voyez
là on n'est plus là on est carrément
aussi dans cet ordre d'idées donc le
tyrannosaurus il a le cerveau d'un hip
hop au tableau darin aux séances voilà
ça marche aussi c'est à peu près dans
cet ordre de grandeur là c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il faut toujours corriger
la taille du cerveau par rapport à la
taille du corps parce que sinon vous
avez les chimpanzés des principaux
thèmes qui ont la même taille de cerveau
et si vous vous servez que de la taille
du cerveau pour estimer l'intelligence
vous allez vous allez conclure que
l'hippopotame et les chimpanzés ont
exactement la même intelligence
je vous rappelle qu'en paléo neurologie
on est condamné à regarder la taille du
cerveau
c'est pas parce que j'ai envie de
regarder la taille du cerveau que je
vous dis ça c'est on est condamné à
regarder la taille du cerveau donc on
essaye quand même de ne pas dire des
conneries c'est pour ça qu'il faut
toujours regarder la taille du cerveau
par rapport au corps
on verra pourquoi c'est important un peu
plus tard
donc tyrannosaurus quatre cents 400 g 20
400 300 400 centimètres cubes de cerveau
là le pourcentage
de ce cerveau qui est réellement dédié à
réfléchir n'est que de 30% c'est à dire
que il ya globalement il ya qu' un tiers
de ceux de cette masse cérébrale qui
n'est réellement dédié qu'à la réflexion
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le thé lancé
fallon ou le cérébral donc c'est ce qui
correspond pour nous aux hémisphère là
où se trouve le néocortex
tyrannosaurus n'avait vraisemblablement
pas de néo cortex ici vous avez les
hémisphères vous voyez que c'est
vraiment là qu'il se trouvait vous voyez
qu'ils sont pas très développée
d'ailleurs en gros vous avez un tiers de
cerveau c'est du lobe olfactif à
l'arrière des hémisphères vous avez
encore un gros tiers plus qu'un gros
tiers du cerveau enfin de l'umih l'agent
de crânien qui est fait de nerfs de
ménage et de ce2 cervelet donc ouais y'a
vraiment visuellement en fait ça se voit
bien qu'il ya qu' un tiers du cerveau
qui est réellement dédié à ce qu'on
pourrait appeler réfléchir voilà
moulinet de l'information et c'est donc
cette surface qui est représentée ici en
gris on a coupé l'élan golf actifs ici
mais c'est la surface qui vous est
représentée ici en gris donc et en plus
là ils ont été généreux ils ont été très
généreux parce que ils n'ont pas
soustrait le fait que chez les reptiles
en fait le cerveau ne touche pas les
parois du crâne donc il ya une épaisseur
de ménage épaisseur de ménage qui comme
je voulais rappeler tout à l'heure est
d'autant plus épaisse et autant plus
grande que l'animal est grand et que du
coup il a un gros cerveau c'est juste
une fonction à l'eau métriques et il n'y
a pas de raison particulière à ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle de la lho maîtrise et
ça se passe comme ça point c'est tout et
ça c'est intéressant parce que du coup
là en fait ils disent qu'il ya 30 % donc
de ces quatre de ses 300 400 centimètres
cubes qui sont dédiées à l'intelligence
j'ai envie de dire à la réflexion
vraiment géré de l'information
en réalité il ya un an à la moitié de sa
psy on suit la quantité de cerveau qu il
y a dans un moule à jean do crânien
d'une espèce modernes ont par exemple
une tortue ou un lézard en fait le
cerveau ne remplit que la moitié du
volume endocriniens et là tout ce qu'on
a c'est le volume endocrânienne donc il
faudrait encore enlever la moitié de ça
donc là ça vous donne un cerveau sur 300
400 centimètres cubes de cerveau il y en
a que 50 en réalité qui servirait à
faire quelque chose
au lieu de 100 au lieu de 100 g ici au
lieu de cinq centimètres cubes d g et
les centimètres cube c'est la même chose
puisque le cerveau c'est de la flotte
globalement c'est comme tout tissu
vivant qui ne contient pas de dos vous
pouvez dire que c'est de la flotte ça la
même densité donc g et centimètre cube
c'est la même chose donc pour un cerveau
de
200 centimètres cubes enfin pour un
nando crâne pardon de centimètres cubes
en fait si vous suivez la règle qui
s'applique aux reptiles moderne il n'y
aurait que la moitié de ces 100
centimètres cubes qui serait réellement
cérébrale donc réellement du cerveau
donc ça vous laisse plus que 50
centimètres cubes de matière cérébrale
une fois le cervelet exclu une fois les
lobes olfactif est exclu et une fois les
ménages exclu
bon bah
là comme ça si vous me demandez mon avis
je vous dirais qu t-rex hibri brillait
pas par son intelligence voilà il
brillait pas par son intelligence et il
devait pas avoir un comportement très
complexe ce qu'on qualifierait nous de
très complexe je vous rappelle que la
complexité j'aime pas ça j'aime pas le
mot complexe en soi mais il aurait pas
des comportements que nous en tant
qu'humain qualifierions de élaborer
des comportements plus que la base en
gros plus que les réglages de base boire
manger dormir se reproduire
genre la vie en société tout ça on va
voir qui on va voir qu'il ya des données
solides qui nuance ce que je suis en
train de vous dire là mais globalement
s'il fallait juste regarder le cerveau
on partirait pas sur un animal très
social avec un soin parental très
compliqué on partirait pas sur un animal
capable de stratégie de ouf 1 donc oui
comme je disais boire manger dormir se
reproduire
ça c'est si on regarde uniquement le
cerveau est on
ceci étant dit quand on commence à
comparer la taille de cerveau t-rex par
rapport à son par rapport à ses
congénères et qu on la corrige surtout
par rapport au poids du corps on se rend
on se rend compte donc là on a le poids
du corps à l'horizontale ici et à la
verticale vous avez le volume
endocriniens en bleu ici vous avez les
oiseaux
est ici là de toutes les couleurs vous
avez les dinosaures non aviens donc
tyrannosaurus rex vous voyez il se
trouve tout là haut parce qu'évidemment
il a une taille corporelle plus grande
que la plupart des dinosaures enfin là
c'est les dinosaures théropodes non
aviens je crois qu'ils sont pas inclus
si vous incluez brachiosaures votre
graphie
il part faire un tour du côté de chez
swann et vous le reverrez jamais enfin
c'est surtout qui devient illisible
parce qu'il part tellement loin là bas
avec son poids du corps gigantesque que
on n'arrive plus à lire les graphes mai
donc là il ya que les théropodes et vous
voyez que ici là vous avez la droite de
régression donc la moyenne
pour les théropodes et vous voyez que
tyrannosaurus au final il est
confortablement sur la moyenne de tous
et théropodes et que c'est théropodes
inclut des trucs qu'on aurait tendance à
considérer comme intelligent vous avez
vous avez notamment de vous avez
archéoptéryx ici premiers oiseaux donc
là il est il exclu justement des oiseaux
il est considéré comme un terreau pod
bon bah déjà parce que ça nous intéresse
de savoir où tombent archéoptéryx donc
on l'exclût un peu pour essayer de voir
oui parlons le l'illuminent d'une façon
différente là il est en vert c'est le
seul à être en verre justement pour
pouvoir le voir et donc là il est
confortablement pareil sur la droite de
régression donc la moyenne des
dinosaures non aviens ici vous avez ign
sans 1126 qui est un trop dont il est
vous rappeler les trop haute idée 1 les
fameux les fameux truc qui sont censés
être tellement intelligents qu'ils
auraient donné une civilisation
parallèle reptilienne si seulement la
météorite était pas tombé etc etc elle
est trop gentil des bains alors certains
légèrement plus en ses valises et que
les archéoptéryx ce qui est surprenant
ce qui est intéressant du moins
légèrement plus à ses valises écart qui
optaient rixe mais encore assez loin de
la droite de régression des oiseaux la
droite de régression des oiseaux c'est
pointillés l'allégro pointillés que vous
voyez là et la droite au milieu c'est la
régression pour tout le monde donc là la
droite de régression des oiseaux elle et
elle est loin de notre troodontidés et
même la droite de régression pour tout
le monde et loin donc les trois ans dont
il est en réalité ils se conforment
assez bien à ce qu'on voit chez les
autres dinosaures donc voilà là des
bonnes cage en règle non les trop haute
idée non pas un cerveau spécialement
gros ici vous avez des envies raptor et
si vous aviez un
si vous aviez à drôme et aux orres ce
dont je ne suis pas sûr
mais si vous avez un drôme et aux orres
globalement il tomberait aussi dans ces
coins là des nonick us
il n'a pas été mesuré je crois c'est
bambiraptor qui a été mesurée pour une
raison que j'ignore j'ignore ils n'ont
pas inclus dans ce graphe m'aider nonick
us il tomberait aussi par là du côté des
rouges enfin pas d'ennemis q justement
bambiraptor il tomberait du côté des
rouges le problème c'est que c'est un
juvénile je crois gambie raptor donc en
fait il a l'air d'avoir un plus gros
cerveau mais juste parce qu'il a un plus
petit corps encore une fois problème
dalo mettrie les bébés enfin les
juvéniles ont un cerveau relativement
plus gros par rapport au poids de leur
corps donc général c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'ils l'ont exclu
bref tyrannosaurus ils se conforment
assez bien à ce qu'on voit chez les
autres théropodes donc il n'a pas un
cerveau spécialement si petit que ça
voyez il est juste bien sur la droite il
a pas un cerveau si petit que ça pour un
terreau potes pour à dinosaures non
aviens théropodes pour interpol non à
bien par contre comparé aux oiseaux il
est loin d'avoir la taille de cerveau
d'un oiseau moderne et quand on compare
donc aux oiseaux modernes et aux
reptiles justement donc ce café larsson
et à l'an 2000
on voit qu'il est finalement donc là on
a deux droite de régression celle des
oiseaux ici celle des reptiles en bas
avec les points noirs c'est les reptiles
les oiseaux c'est en blanc
et donc ce qu'on voit ici c'est qu'il ya
une espèce de l'intervalle de confiance
marquée par ces pointillés et
tyrannosaure se trouve finalement à la
jonction entre ces deux intervalles de
confiance en fait donc il est vraiment
il est vraiment là où on attendrait si
vous voulez à interros pod non aviens
relativement dérivés phylogénétiquement
assez haut dans la dans l'histoire des
dinosaures
mais pas suffisamment haut pour être
considéré comme un oiseau il serait il
est vraiment oui bah intermédiaire en
fait entre les reptiles et les oiseaux
comme l'archaeopteryx d'ailleurs voyez
qu'il est là on pourrait limite croîtra
c'est une droite de régression ici qui
passerait par tyrannosaurus et
archaeopteryx et vous voyez qu'il serait
qui serait qu'ils formeraient une droite
qui serait bien parallèles entre les
reptiles et les oiseaux donc
tyrannosaurus rex n'a pas à une taille
de cerveau qui dénote franchement par
rapport aux autres théropodes menant à
bien
donc si on devait finalement pointé une
origine de l'intelligence dans cette
histoire bas la seule intelligence en
fête à laquelle on et access et celle
des reptiles moderne et c'est celle des
oiseaux modernes et en fait on aurait
tyrannosaurus qui serait finalement
quelque part entre les deux donc voyez
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
intéressant d'avoir des des approches
chiffres et c'est parce que si on
s'était juste arrêté sur la morphologie
du cerveau et la taille apparente du thé
l'encéphale comme je lé fais au début
ben on se serait dit la vache
tyrannosaure a été con
et non en fait pas tant que ça pas pas
tant que ça et on contraire même
peut-être intermédiaire entre les
oiseaux les reptiles donc on pourrait
s'autoriser maintenant basé sur ces
données chiffrées oms autoriserait
éventuellement à ay faire l'hypothèse de
comportements qui seraient pas si boire
manger boire manger dormir se reproduire
que ça donc c'est ça relativise un petit
peu la proche que j'ai fait tout à
l'heure alors il ya un article
maintenant on va aller un peu plus loin
et un article qui va sortir enfin du
moins je sais qu'il a été soumis et
mais qu'il a été rejetée et re soumis et
tout ça enfin il a fait du ping pong un
peu il n'est pas encore sorti mais il
est accessible en prix print est
l'auteur et recule à noël qu'on a vu sur
l'évolution des proboscidiens
la publier sur en pré print est là elle
a déclaré sur twitter donc c'est que
c'est qu'elle est d'accord pour qu'on le
site au final c'est qu'elle est d'accord
pour qu'on en parle pour qu'on en
discute donc on va en discuter et
notamment ben elle a pris le nombre de
neurones enfin elle a essayé de
reconstituer à partir de là des
dimensions de l'endocrâne justement le
nombre de neurones qu'il y avait chez
les espèces éteintes et notamment chez
les dinosaures et en ce qu'elle trouve
c'est que ben hatira novascale trouve
c'est pas très surprenant c'est qu'un
tyrannosaurus avec un cerveau donc de
l'ordre de 300 400 grammes bas se
retrouve avec un nombre de neurones
assez proche de ce qu'on retrouve chez
les primates avec un cerveau de 300 400
grammes
évidemment si on part du principe que le
cerveau est une boîte qui contient une
certaine quantité de neurones alors plus
la boîte est grande et plus il y aura de
neurones et donc deux boîtes de la même
taille devrait normalement contenir le
même nombre de neurones et donc elle en
conclut que tyrannosaurus et beaucoup
d'autres dinosaures devez posséder le
même nombre de neurones que les primates
que des primates qu'on considère comme
relativement intelligents tels que le
chimpanzé par exemple alors je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs raisons pour laquelle
l'article a été rejetée la première
c'est déjà que comparer les
comparer les dinosaures non aviens à des
primates c'est les comparer à des
mammifères et donc la comparaison est
pas très pertinentes j'ai envie de dire
la comparaison n'est pas super
pertinentes et limite est allé à même
limite un peu parce que même si on ne
prononce pas le mot intelligence en fait
même ce jeu me rappelle pas qu'elle
parle réellement d'intelligence il est
même je crois que suis en fait mais bref
même si on ne prononce pas le mot
intelligence le fait d'aller chercher
les primates
comme élément de comparaison avec des
dinosaures alors que c'est pas
spécialement peur sinon faudrait les
comparer à des oiseaux ain il ya des
perroquets par exemple donc faudrait
comparer des oiseaux ça suggère
immédiatement en fait un
anthropocentrisme ça suggère
immédiatement qu'en fait vous voulez
parler d'intelligence vous vous êtes en
train de suggérer
que tyrannosaurus avait plane neurones
alors ce sont des neurones tel
encéphalique donc ce sont vraiment les
neurones qui servent à réfléchir en
l'occurrence je précise avant qu'on me
dise que ces neurones du cervelet non
non c'est les neurones telle
encéphalique les neurones du cervelet il
servirait effectivement à coordonner là
encore ordonner le tout ce qui est les
fonctions motrices et on s'attend
effectivement à ce qu'un animal de 7
tonnes de 6 à 7 tonnes et beaucoup de
neurones dans son cervelet mais là il
s'agit bien des neurones telle
encéphalique ce qui certes à
l'intelligente donc on mesure la
quantité de neurones telle encéphalique
enfin estime pardon la quantité de
neurones telle encéphalique et ensuite
on la compare à des espèces modernes les
primates alors que c'est pas
spécialement pertinents a priori bon ça
sent un petit peu
les 500 beaucoup d'ailleurs quelqu'un
qui a envie de nous dire hey regardez
tyrannosaurus il était aussi intelligent
cachin pas et
ce qui me conduit à ma deuxième
remarque la deuxième raison qui à mon
avis a conduit cet article à être rejeté
puis re soumis enfin à faire du ping
pong comme ça c'est qu'à mon avis il ya
des reviewer des la revue par le système
de revue par les pairs a un peu de mal à
digérer le fait qu'on raisonne en valeur
absolue de nombre de neurones pour
estimer l'intelligence
parce que si la valeur absolue du nombre
de neurones pour estimer l'intelligence
était une mesure qui marchaient à tous
les coups bas ça fait longtemps que les
baleines devrait avoir envoyer des
fusées dans l'espace
ça ferait 30 millions d'années est en
réalité que les baleines devrait avoir
envoyer des fusées dans l'espace
comme on l'a vu dans notre évolution des
du cerveau des cétacés le cerveau des
des cétacés ça fait à peu près 30
millions d'années qu'il a la forme et la
taille qu'on lui connaît aujourd'hui
donc
ça devrait faire 30 millions d'années
que les dauphins devrait être dans
l'espace et avoir fait la fameuse
chanson soul on gagne 5 folle de fiches
ceux qui connaissent h2g2 évidemment
sinon bah allez voir h2g2 c'est un très
beau film c'est très très marrant très
second degré et donc donc donc oui la
quantité de neurones en valeur absolue
et d'ailleurs la taille du cerveau en
valeur absolue et toute forme de mesure
en valeur absolue ça se manipule chez
des animaux qui ont des tailles
comparables
parce qu'en valeur absolue
en valeur absolue vous allez vite avoir
un effet de la taille du corps qui va
jouer si jamais vous avez des animaux
qui sont pas de taille comparable genre
un archéoptéryx de quelques grammes et
un tyrannosaurus de plusieurs tonnes
pourquoi parce que on ne s'attend pas un
ce qu'un animal de grande taille est des
petits organes un animal de grande
taille va forcément avoir des plus
grands tout le monde est plus grosse
vertèbres un plus gros fois plus gros
système digestif des plus grosses jambes
en valeur absolue qu'un animal de petite
taille et là où ça devient justement
intéressant à discuter c'est quand il y
a quelque chose d'inattendu qui se
produit genre des petits bras puisqu'on
parle des tyrannosaures à l'aller
tyrannosaure aussi à l'année voici des
animaux gigantesques que c'est
tyrannosauridés
avec des tout petits bras les
tyrannosaures au idylle avait des bras
relativement normaux les tyrannosaures
aux ide non tyrannosauridés leurs
ancêtres donc ils avaient des bradeux
proportion relativement normale avec
trois doigts et d'un seul coup chez les
terrano au rider chez tyrannosauridés
même en particulier vous vous retrouvez
avec des tout petits bras avec deux
petites des petits crochets alan oil qui
savent plus à rien ça c'est intéressant
à discuter parce que justement on se
dégage de la tendance qu'on s'attend à
voir à savoir un gros animal qui aura
une grosse tête et des gros bras et des
grosses jambes et une grosse queue et
des gros organes de manière générale
donc ce qui est intéressant à discuter
c'est quand on s'écarte de la tente
et donc les petits bras de t-rex à
partir du moment où on constate qu'il ya
des petits bras on se pose immédiatement
la question mais pourquoi ces petits
bras bon bah probablement parce qu'il
servait à rien
parce qu'il servait à rien et qu'en plus
il était dans le passage quand ils se
bouffent et la tronche 1 je rappelle que
les tyrannosaures on a de bonnes preuves
là qu'ils se bouffent et la tronche et
donc quand il se bouche mais la tronche
bas il y avait les bras dans le passage
et dans les bras il ya des grosses
artères qui passait donc en plus elles
sont situées juste à côté du coeur pour
celle là et de fait bas de fait si vous
arracher le bras vous fait arracher le
bras vous risquez de vider vous videz de
votre sang pour un organe dont au final
vous vous servez pas réellement un peu
comme les oiseaux de proie moderne les
oiseaux de proie moderne et se servent
de leur bouche ils se servent de leurs
griffes mais savent pas de leurs bras
donc il ya une forte pression de
sélection pour que les bras deviennent
de plus en plus petits
chez tyrannosaurus donc on a cherché
comme ça des explications pour arriver à
pour arriver à justifier l'existant la
réduction des bras chez tyrannosaurus
pour ça que ça me fais c'est pour ça que
ça me fait un peu tiquer à chaque fois
qu'on essaie de trouver une fonction au
bras de tyrannosaurus c'est bah oui mais
vous vous rendez bien compte que tout ce
que vous dites là si ça si ça servait à
gripper who has a agrippé la femelle ou
ça servait à aider à se relever enfin si
ça servait à quelque chose les bras
tyrannosaurus il n'y a rien que les bras
de tyrannosaurus
peuvent faire dans leur état actuel
qu'il ne ferait pas mieux en étant plus
grand
c'est à dire agrippé la femelle ça
marcherait mieux avec trois doigts et
des grands draps
se relever ça marcherait beaucoup mieux
avec trois doigts et des grands bras
comme leurs ancêtres il n'y a aucune
fonction dont vous pouvez faire
l'hypothèse
pour les braves tyrannosaurus qui ne
marcherait pas mieux s'ils étaient plus
grand ses bras donc en fait vous
raisonnez à l'envers et là c'est ce qui
est aussi en train de se produire là
c'est au lieu de raisonner sur les
choses qui s'écartent de la moyenne mais
là on essaie de les ramener vers la
moyenne et non la cie si vous ne corrige
et pas pour la taille général du corps
ben en fait on voit plus rien on voit
plus rien c'est
fin du mois on ne voit pas ce qu'on est
censé voir le cerveau de tyrannosaurus
par rapport à son corps il a l'air petit
d'où les approches quantifier que je
vous ai montré qui par comparaison
montre que bon bah finalement non par
rapport à aux autres dinosaures
théropodes on a bien ça va à tirano aux
russes il n'est pas si bizarre que ça
mais n'empêche que la première vue on
quand on a vu que j'espère que quand
vous avez vu ce tout petit cerveau dans
cet énorme tête quand je voulais montrer
vous vous êtes dit waouw c'est minuscule
un cerveau tyrannosaure en fait ça il
faut il faut corriger par rapport à la
taille du corps parce qu'on ne s'attend
pas à autre chose que un gros animal est
des gros organes effectivement rapporté
à la taille du corps finalement
tyrannosaures et relativement normal
niveau de la taille de son cerveau par
contre ses bras sont excessivement petit
et ça ça demande une explication voilà
c'est là où je veux en venir
et donc là on raisonne en valeur absolue
de nombre de neurones alors qu'en
réalité à mon avis il faudrait en parler
relativement encore une fois la taille
du corps c'est relativement à la taille
du camp même s'il avait je ne nie pas
qu'il ait pu avoir ce nombre de neurones
là mais le fait de le comparer aux
primates
suggèrent un effet de ce nombre de
neurones sur l'intelligence général
c'est la comparaison en fait avec les
primates qui dit m et didon est-ce qu'il
serait pas aussi intelligent qu'un
chimpanzé ben non il faut ramener tout
ça à la taille du corps ne serait ce que
parce que dans le ne serait ce que parce
que dans le dans la partie cérébrale va
se jouer tout ce qui est sensibilité par
exemple la sensibilité notamment de la
peau si vous avez 40 kg de pommes
en l'occurrence tyrannosaure ouais on
doit littéralement par les deux kilos de
pau en plus par rapport à un chimpanzé
évidemment que il va y avoir plus d'un
flux nerveux en direction du cerveau et
donc on a besoin d'un cerveau plus gros
par voilà ça peut être une des multiples
explications pour laquelle un cerveau un
cerveau de tyrannosaure a besoin d'être
plus gros c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de peau donc plus d'influx nerveux
et c'est la face aussi un je vous
rappelle il ya plus de surface sur le
museau donc le nerf trijumeau et plus
gros donc le donc tout ça faut que ça
parte au cerveau d'une façon ou d'une
autre et faut que le cerveau le gère
la taille du corps c'est important il
faut en tenir compte je pense donc on
verra si c'est publier ou pas et
peut-être qu'elle va changer aussi ses
conclusions je remets pas en question
comme j'ai dit l'estimation du nombre de
neurones c'est pas surprenant qu'un gros
animal et beaucoup de neurones puisqu'il
aura un plus gros cerveau fatalement en
valeur absolue par contre en valeur
relative c'est là que tout se joue à mon
avis tout se joue dans la valeur
relative
bref et donc c'est tout ça et c'est
évidemment basé sur des estimations ce
café et recule à naurouze elle s'est
basée sur des estimations du nombre de
neurones ce qui a motivé son approche en
fait c'est je pense le fait que chez les
oiseaux on a mesuré qu'en fait les
oiseaux avaient beaucoup plus de
neurones à taille égale que les
mammifères et notamment que les primates
donc c'est ce que vous voyez
représentait alors là c'est représenter
évidemment de façon simplifiée
c'est-à-dire dans un plus petit cerveau
il ya plus de neurones parce qu'ils sont
plus petits et plus condensée que dans
un cerveau de mammifères ou comme je
vous avais dit les mammifères ils vont
augmenter la quantité de la quantité de
travail possibles par l'ordinateur en
augmentant la taille de l'ordinateur
alors que les alors que les oiseaux
finalement ils vont aller vers le
microprocesseur vers la miniaturisation
pour des raisons évidentes de conserver
un cerveau de taille raisonnable tout en
tout en ayant aussi de l'intelligence en
plus
en tout cas c'est comme ça que c'est
interprété évidemment comme je vous ai
dis à chaque fois qu'on est sûr de la
taille du cerveau on parle
d'intelligence
et donc ça se voit sur ce graphe ici
puisque là vous avez le nombre de
neurones à l'horizontale la taille du
cerveau en à la verticale est donc ici
vous avez les son goût bird donc les
passes et reform et les perroquets ici
qui sont sur à peu près la même ligne là
qui est une ligne qui est dirigée
beaucoup plus du côté taille de neurones
du côté de nombre de neurones que ne
l'est celle des primates en bleu ici
donc ça veut dire que les primates à
taille égale au moins de neurones dans
leur cerveau que les séries forme et les
perroquets ceci étant dit ça que pour
les passes et avait formé des perroquets
puisque vous avez d'autres oiseaux ici
en noir donc vous avez la colombe ici en
vous avez la colombe vous avez un émeu
ici vous avez
une poule ici alors hélas ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de
et vous avez un rapace ici je crois aux
noirs ici donc vous n'avez pas beaucoup
d'oiseaux qui ne soit ni des perroquets
ni dépasser reform ce qui est à peu près
ce qu'on retrouve dans la nature
actuelle énormément de passer à la forme
elle est passée reform ça contient les
corvidés les corvidés sont dépassés
reform en tout cas c'est ce que m'a dit
miss plume
je pensais pas que les corvidés était
dépassée reform mais apparemment s'ils
se sont dépassés réforme donc cette
ligne verte là elle inclut les corvidés
donc vous avez les corvidés et les
perroquets qui ont évidemment qu'ils
sont très intelligents qui ont un gros
cerveau et qui ont en plus beaucoup de
neurones dans leur cerveau beaucoup plus
que les primates de même poids et dans
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est de
regarder que les autres oiseaux en fait
eux ils sont plutôt centré autour de la
courbe des primates et pas du tout celle
des perroquets et dépasser reform donc
c'est pas la condition de base des
oiseaux c'est une condition dérivés qui
a évolué chez dépasser les formes et les
perroquets
donc il est plus probable quand même que
les dinosaures se comportent comme des
oiseaux de base que comme des perroquets
ou dès
que comme des perroquets ou dépassé
reform donc en l'occurrence des corvidés
donc est-ce que ça là est-ce que ça là
cette haute concentration de tous petits
neurones d'entre elles dans un très
petit cerveau s'applique effectivement
aux dinosaures non aviens
je sais pas je dirais je dirais point
d'interrogation je ne partirai pas du
principe que c'est le cas en tout cas
donc est-ce que ça c est ce que ça ça
finira publié je pense que si ça finit
publier ça finira publié avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de
beaucoup plus de conditionnel dans le
texte est beaucoup plus de nuances on va
dire comme j'ai dit je remets pas en
question le nombre de neurones mais par
contre le fait de comparer aux primates
suggère une intelligence similaire et ça
c'est un petit peu c'est border c'est
borders pourrait changer les primates
avec les passes et réformer les passes
et les formes et les perroquets
mais peut-être mais comme yao k le
problème c'est qu'il ya aucun oiseaux
modernes qui atteint une taille de 400 g
de cerveau veut dire qu'ils ont tous des
tout petits cerveaux même la aepyornis
on n'a pas d'estimation du poids du
cerveau de la hippie ornis qui est donc
l'oiseau géant de madagascar
on n'a pas d'estimation de la taille du
cerveau accessible dans la littérature
mais il devait avoir un cerveau qui
devait faire au maximum
la moitié de la taille de celui d'un
t-rex voire même peut-être qu'un tiers
c'était très je veux dire t-rex il et il
est hors normes au niveau de ses
dimensions générales
c'est comme les cétacés en fait c'est
toujours le même problème qu'avec les
cétacés cd que vous commencez à parler
d'animaux qui sont hors normes en termes
de taille bah vous finissez avec des
résultats qui doivent être extrêmement
nuancé en termes de taille de cerveau
parce que il faut comparer le comparable
quoi
et puis la dernière raison la dernière
le dernier élément j'ai envie de dire
pour discuter de l'intelligence de t-rex
du mois sur visible sur son cerveau
c'est l'absence de ce qu'on appelle le
bouliste leboulch w eu l est et je crois
que c'est un mot allemand mais j'en suis
pas sûr donc le bouliste c7 quand vous
regardez les oiseaux modernes ici tout à
droite
vous avez ici cette petite ce petit
renfoncement qui délimite un petit lob
du cerveau qui correspond à peu près à
l'endroit où on s'attend à trouver le
néocortex chez les mammifères bon balle
aux boulistes finalement c'est plus ou
moins le néocortex des mammifères en
réalité
visible sur l'endocrâne donc le l'a7
cette ligne là ça correspondrait
finalement à la scie sur inhalent sur le
rhin en doc ran de mammifères alors
c'est très très approximatif parce que
les oiseaux n'ont pas de réel néocortex
ce qu'ils ont ce sont des nucleix
le bull sts elle l'a de ces nucleix mais
ils ne sont pas tous là et encore une
fois on parle d'un corps et la hausse
théologique d'une structure qui à la
base et neuronale donc c'est pareil là
on tira l'approximatif on compte sur la
précise enfin ouais on compte sur la
justesse mais pas tellement sur la
précision voilà donc on espère qu'on
touche la cible avec les yeux fermés
comme ça
mais mais mais mais mais on compte pas
sur les bons compte pas sur le fait que
les bastos aillent directement au milieu
de la cible quoi clairement en espèces
on espère paraître trop à côté de la
cible voilà quand on parle du boult et
qu'on le et qu'on le compare aux néo
cortex d'un mammifère c'est un peu ça
donc on compare le pas comparable mais
n'empêche que l'existence de ce moule
sts c'est quelque chose qui est
considéré de fait comme un élément
important dans l'intelligence à vienne
et semoule sts est notamment très
développée chez les corvidés et chez les
petites acide et si je ne m'abuse
archéoptéryx n'en avaient pas les
dinosaures non aviens ici non pas le
évidemment le l'alligator non plus enfin
le les crocodiliens non plus n'en avait
pas ici vous avez alliaura muschi il me
semble est un tyrannosauridés mais bref
tyrannosaurus rex n'y en avait pas de
ceux de boules sts évidemment donc seul
le boulch c'est quelque chose qui a
évolué très très tard dans l'histoire de
l'histoire des oiseaux et pour l'instant
ça a été publié en 2021 le premier
oiseau à posséder un moule stss et
ichthys ornis il tire nice qui est donc
ce très célèbres oiseaux marins avec des
dents qui vivait au crétacé en amérique
du nord donc voilà vous avez un joli
crâne dicter aux rites nice il a encore
des dents comme un dinosaure mais c'est
déjà un oiseau pour tout le reste de son
anatomie la même un début de petits becs
sur son pré maxillaire et donc hilti
ornis il a aussi un bouliste là alors il
est pas très visible il n'est pas bien
préservé mais vous avez définitivement
un petit renfoncement ici sur le moulage
en os crânien qui correspond à ce petit
renfoncement que vous voyez là
et donc pour conclure sur le cerveau de
et l'intelligence de tyrannosaurus
tyrannosaurus avait un cerveau
relativement petit pas beaucoup plus
petit que les autres dinosaures que les
autres théropodes mon avis un
raptor inclus et il avait il était à peu
près comme les autres dinosaures non
aviens intermédiaire entre la condition
reptilienne la condition à vienne et il
était dépourvu d'une structure qu'on
pourrait comparer aux néo cortex des
mammifères donc
intelligence des tyrannosauridés
je lui donnerai suite si je devais l'a
notée sur 20 enfin si je devais noter
les attentes que j'ai sur l'intelligence
des tyrannosauridés sur 20 je lui
mettrais 5 voilà c'est à dire par
rapport aux oiseaux qui seraient vains
et aux reptiles qui serait 0 voilà
sachant que les reptiles irait en
réalité de 0 à 3 et les oiseaux irait de
15 à 20 je pense
basiquement je lui mettrais way entre 5
et 8 on va dire donc même pas
où aller peut-être plus proche de 8 plus
proche de la moyenne allez soyons
généreux
ça c'est l'intelligence que j'attendrais
maintenant les vraies preuves
d'intelligence qu'on a enfin
d'intelligence de comportements qu'on a
de tyrannosaurus bas c'est pareil on en
a des preuves de comportements de
tyrannosaurus et alors est ce que ces
preuves de comportements indique de
l'intelligence bon bah on va les passer
en revue donc on n'avait notamment pas
encore une fois la question prédateurs
ou charognards avec un petit cerveau on
se dirait plutôt charognards parce que
ben a
pourchassé faut être intelligent se dit
on entend que mammifères bon bah en
l'occurrence le cerveau de tyrannosaurus
n'est pas si petit que ça en tout cas
pas plus petit que celui pas
significativement plus petit que celui
d'un chasseur confirmé comme comme un
drôme et aux orres par exemple comme un
raptor donc a priori c'est pas une bonne
excuse et on a des preuves physiques que
tyrannosaurus était un chasseur on a des
preuves évidentes ici vous avez la
vertèbre d'un add rose or avec une dent
de t-rex planté à l'intérieur et on sait
que cette dent n'a pas été planté durant
un acte de charognards parce que il ya
un gros tissu de guérison autour ce
qu'on appelle un call us et là on le
voit bien ce cas lui si les gigantesques
donc ça veut dire que la dent a été
planté dans la queue danse et des
vertèbres caudales donc cette dent a été
planté dans la queue d'un adro szohr que
7 à drouot d'or s'est barré que la danse
et péter dans la queue et que 1 qu'à
l'us de cicatrisation s'est formé autour
de cette dent alors que la drosophile
était toujours vivant ce qui veut dire
que la dhr other était vivant quand le
tyrannosaurus l'a attaqué et on est sûr
que c'est tyrannosaurus parce que là
dedans il y est toujours et que donc on
a pu identifier tyrannosaurus
formellement à partir de cette banque
donc le débat j'ai envie de dire
prédateurs ou charognards il est clos
depuis 2012
tyrannosaurus était capable d'actes de
chasse points
alors après il va il va sharon y est
comme tous les grands carnivores et la
grande question ça va être la proportion
de charogne dans son régime alimentaire
mais il y a une proportion existantes de
proies et on ne peut pas partir du
principe que le registre fossile a
enregistré quelque chose d'exceptionnel
mans rare aussi parce qu'évidemment la
fossilisation c'est un miracle en soi
donc il faut pas partir du principe que
ce qui a été fossilisé être
exceptionnellement rare on parle d'un
comportement qui est suffisamment
fréquents pour avoir laissé une trace
dans le registre fossile
donc tyrannosaure chasseurs aux
prédateurs ou charognards le débat est
clos depuis 2012 ces prédateurs ceci
étant dit ça n'exclut pas qu'il ait pu
sharon y ait une fois de temps en temps
et comme j'ai dit il avait des
adaptations notamment le fact yves
similaire un certain sharon ya encore
que on les a on a relativisé cette
adaptation en montrant qu' il n'était
pas si différent que ça d'un alligator
qui n'est pas un charognard particulier
donc une fois de plus les et on a parlé
aussi de ce fameux de ce fameux optique
le lobe optique et le lobe du cervelet
le paraphe l'opl le lobe paraphe
l'oculaire du cervelet qui sont pas très
développée chez tyrannosaurus et qui du
coup l'aurait empêché de de pratiquer
une chasse active une chasse activer des
urnes donc on était peut-être sur un
chasseur qui chassait en embûches ou
alors qu'ils ne chassait que des
individus enfin que des espèces
relativement lente on sait qu'ils
chassaient des adrs or et
ddc rate obtient donc il chassait
peut-être des proies qui était
relativement lente et les chasser en
embûches
ce qui du coup expliquerait pourquoi il
avait un tout petit des tout-petits
l'aube optique et des tout petits lobs
flow cullers du cervelet
voilà où on en est pour le comportement
de chasse
on a d'ailleurs tellement de on a
d'ailleurs tellement de traces sur des
cératopsidés notamment qu on a même une
idée assez claire donc c'est fort leurs
étals qui ont publié ça en 2002 on a
même une idée assez claire de comment
ils dépiauter
leur ceyrat obtient pour allez en manger
les muscles du cou les muscles du cou
donc c'est vraiment la partie la partie
goûteuse du serrat obtient la collerette
protège ses muscles du cou et empêchent
l'accès à ses muscles du cou donc si on
a des traces de dents qui montrent très
clairement la séquence de dépiautage du
crâne d'acerra tu obtiens afin de
pouvoir accéder à cette partie juteuse
les muscles du cou des cératopsidés donc
c'est un top 16 avec des gros muscles du
cou parce qu'ils avaient une grosse tête
donc forcément plus on a une grosse tête
et plus il faut des deux forces dans la
nuque pour pouvoir la soutenir
donc voilà comment tu iras on a même
voilà des traces de comportement de
tyrannosaure au point que l'on sait
comment il des pilotait en fait ses
proches trouve ça assez impressionnant
tyrannosaure ils chassent et aussi donc
on maintenant qu'on est con a confirmé
que tyrannosaurus it est un prédateur on
a essayé d'élaborer du coup autour de
ces stratégies de chasse et alors il ya
un truc qui ressort systématiquement dès
qu'on se met à étudier les stratégies de
chasse chez tyrannosaure c'est la
puissance hallucinante
de ses muscles on n'a pas de muscles de
tyrannosaure mais par contre les points
d'attaché des muscles les muscles
temporaux et les muscles perrigault ide
dont je vous avais parlé dans une autre
vidéo
pareil si vous voulez je vous la met
très en lien
manifestez vous donc les muscles
perrigault ide et les muscles temporaux
et les muscles mais c'était rossi donc
ce qui correspond à nos joues à nous les
zygomatiques ses attaches musculaire là
sur le crâne sont titanesques chez
tyrannosaurus rex il ya une des raisons
certainement pour laquelle ils ont l'air
d'avoir un si petit cerveau par rapport
à la taille gigantesque du crâne c'est
parce que vous avez ça de boîte
crânienne et sadate h musculaire
sur le crâne c'est un truc de fou c'est
l'opposé de nous nouons nasa de boîte
crânienne et sadate h musculaire sur les
côtés là c'est l'opposé sa boîte
crânienne dre muscles donc il ya des
muscles absolument titanesque sur le
crâne et quelle que soit la façon en
fait dont on mesure là dont on estime la
force de tyrannosaurus rex donc
généralement s'est basée sur les faits
des reconstitutions reconstitution de
ses muscles on peut les faire en 3d mais
on peut les faire sur papier aussi
séparables et on applique ensuite les
lois physiques n'applique juste les lois
de la physique à ces reconstitutions
musculaire sachant la dimension de ses
muscles et sachant la force d'une fibre
musculaire et donc le nombre de fibres
musculaires dans ses muscles reconstitué
on a reconstitué la force des muscles
quelle que soit la façon dont on estime
sa en se basant sur les crocodiles en se
basant sur les oiseaux etc on arrive
toujours au même résultat tyrannosaure
par rapport à sa taille encore une fois
la taille à l'horizontale avait une
force musculaire ici qui est gigantesque
voilà qui se démarque complètement de
tous les autres dinosaures théropodes on
a des muscles hallucinant de puissance
même comparé à des spinosaures idée même
comparé à giganotosaurus
tyrannosaurus il a des dents justement
ça avait fait dire aussi cette puissance
musculaire associée à des grosses dents
des dents de tyrannosaure camp voulait
couper la section des dents elle est
très épaisse c'est pas des dents en
forme de couteau tyrannosaurus on vous
dit toujours le tyrannosaure avait des
dents aiguisées et tout ça c'est des
conneries c'est des conneries les
tyrannosaures ils avaient des dents
c'était comme je voulais 10 et une
banane la demande à tyrannosaur c'est
une banane ça la taille d'une banane et
quand vous le coupez ça à la section
d'une banane c'est une section qui est
quasiment donc angulaire pas du tout
aiguisait il ya un petit peu de ces
rations dessus mais ça ne va vraiment ça
c'est pas
visuellement ça n'a pas l'air du tout
d'un couteau c'est là dans de
tyrannosaurus c'est une espèce de piston
de broyage
d'ailleurs ça avait fait dire justement
que comme la hyène leyen ondéron d'une
puissance musculaire démesurée et des
dents très épaisse à section pareil très
très très très très large ça avait fait
ça se tenait justement que tyrannosaures
étaient un bonne crashers donc un
broyeur dos un charognard bon leyen on
sait qu'elles sont capables de chasse
aussi mais voilà c'était ça l'idée
c'était de comparer tyrannosaure à la
haine et de dire vous voyez puissance
musculaire démesurée dans broyeuse d'os
égale charognards
et maintenant du coup qu'on a c'est
preuve qu'en fait non pas tant que ça
ben en fait ça montre une stratégie de
chasse qui est assez cohérente justement
avec le chasseur en embûches qui est
tyrannosaurus il a ses dents gigantesque
à section très épaisse ses racines qui
s'enfonce très profondément dans l'os
maxillaire donc des dents qui sont
faites finalement pour ne pas bouger
quand elles sont plantées dans une proie
vivante
on a vraiment sachets tyrannosaurus il
ya ça dedans qui dépasse il ya ça de
d'en planter dans le maxillaire donc il
ya 20 cm 15 20 cm de racine et 10 5 à 10
cm de couronnes qui dépasse 5 cm à 10 cm
de couronnes qui se plante et les 20 cm
de racine qui maintiennent la dent à
l'intérieur du crâne quand la proie ce
débat
pendant que les muscles gigantesque
cette puissance musculaire démesuré
représenter la écrase écrase écrase
c'est un piston en fait faut vous
imaginer un piston c'est comme un boa
constricteur plus il se débat et plus il
resserre donc la stratégie de chasse
d'un tyrannosaure tout se passe comme si
en fait quand on s'intéresse au
comportement et à la neurologie
tyrannosaure en fait on se on s'imagine
un scénario de type tout se passe comme
si tyrannosaure chassé en embûches ou
chasser des animaux relativement lent
les attraper et les lâcher plus ils les
attrape c'est un crâne qui est fait pour
attraper et pas lâcher et plus la mâche
et plus le machin ce débat est plus
sincères et plus ça sert comme un boa
constricteur plus vous débattez plus
vous vous essouffler donc plus vos
poumons ce vide et plus ils écrasent ou
alors il vous chope à la nuque et là il
voit le coup c'est un broyeur ça c'est
un truc de fou ce qui d'ailleurs ce qui
d'ailleurs contraste énormément avec par
exemple ballet les spinosaures idées
notamment spinosaurus à taille
comparable donc crâne à la taille du
crâne de la taille d'une baignoire atari
comparable spinosaurus il a des dents
coniques qui sont vraiment des dents qui
sont juste fait pour attraper du poisson
et il a une puissance musculaire
absolument risible comparé à
tyrannosaurus donc c'est vraiment juste
c'est un art peau en fait un spinosaurus
il n'a pas besoin d'être
particulièrement puissant ils attrapent
il a besoin de vitesse à la limite est
selon buso crocodiliens et
giganotosaurus et une autre stratégie
encore de chasse giganotosaurus lui il a
des dents très très aiguisé donc c'est
un carcharodontosaures idée un peu comme
accro quant aux russes c'est un
carcharodontosaures idées ce qui indique
que ses dents car carreaux dont c'est
cette grand requin blanc parce que il a
des dents comme le grand requin blanc
plate donc longue et fine et acérée avec
des grosses ces rations comme un couteau
à viande donc lui giganotosaurus et
carcharodontosaures russes eux ils ont
vraiment des dents acérées là on peut le
dire et ses dents acérées c'est une
autre stratégie de chasse moins de
puissance musculaire au niveau du crâne
comme indiqué ici vraiment une puissance
musculaire qui passent très
significativement différentes de celles
des autres dinosaures théropodes une
puissance musculaire non pas
spécialement
différentes de celles des deux autres
dinosaures théropodes ce qui indique
qu'en fait cette puissance musculaire
elle était surtout fait pour dépiauter
la chair une fois que l'animal était
mort la stratégie de chasse elle l est
plus donc d'après les dents elle est
plus du type faire des blessures à
répétition c'est à dire traquer une
proie et lui faire des blessures à
répétition jusqu'à ce que la proie
s'effondre exemple en fête ou épuisés
donc là on a une stratégie de chasse qui
implique de suivre la proie pas à pas et
de
la race et de la blesser avec les dents
justement l affaire des morsures est
clair comme ça tac tac à l'emporte-pièce
j'ai envie de dire faire des morsures et
claire jusqu'à ce que la proie se vide
de son sang et s'écroule donc là il ya
besoin de traquer la proie par contre
tyrannosaurus il n'a pas besoin de
traquer sa proie tyrannosaurus comme je
les dis ils l'attrapent ils lâchent plus
c'est tout
et du coup
si vous vous êtes jamais demandé qu'ils
gagnent un combat entre t-rex et
carcharodontosaures us qui gagna combat
entre t-rex et spinosaurus ou t-rex et
n'importe quoi le combat s'est toujours
tyrannosaurus qui gagne
à partir du moment où ils vous attrape
il ne vous lâche plus
-
donc même si vous arrivez à le blesser
mortellement avec vos petits bras ou
avec vos corps nous n'importe quoi de
toute façon une fois qu'il vous a
attrapé ne vous lâchera plus vous êtes
mort donc c'est tyrannosaure qui gagne
il ira mourir il ira se vider de son
sang 20 minutes plus tard un peu plus
loin peut-être
mais c'est lui qui on va gagner
non vraiment il ya la balade dans
jurassic park 3 quand vous voyez ça le
combat est fini le combat il s'arrête là
tyrannosaurus à attraper spinosaurus il
peut faire ce qu'il veut spinosaurus il
ne sortira plus des dents de
tyrannosaurus il le griffera il essaiera
de se dégager et plus il se débattra et
plus les deux ans vont se resserrer sur
sa tronche
tyrannosaurus n'a pas besoin de traquer
il attrape il attend en embuscade
il attrape il hp et tout ça du coup ça
forme une hypothèse cohérente avec tout
ce qu'on sait de la paléo neurologie de
tyrannosaurus rex
du mois mais voilà ce n'est qu'une
hypothèse cohérente on est dans le cadre
je suis pas dans le cadre d'un cours là
je suis du juste dans le cadre d'une
mini conférences sur youtube
du maxi conférence maintenant ça
commence à durer mais on est juste dans
le cas d'une conférence sur youtube on
peut proposer des hypothèses voilà
l'hypothèse basé sur la paléo neurologie
on en est là
d'autres signes du coup de comportement
de tyrannosaure est-ce qu'il chassait
maintenant qu'on voit là un peu le
comportement de chasse sortir de toutes
ces données paléo neurologique et
taphonomie qu du coup on a on se pose la
question ok ça on a cette hypothèse de
chasse de tyrannosaurus mais est-ce que
c'était en meute du coup est-ce que
c'était plutôt solitaire bon alors
chassent en meute ou chasse solitaire le
problème c'est qu'on a pas de preuve la
plupart des empreintes de tyrannosaurus
rex qu'on possède les mêmes de
tyrannosauridés de manière générale
qu'on possède sont isolés un peu comme
celle là là c'est ma petite main que
vous voyez au milieu de ce match c'est
comme ça qu'on identifie une empreinte
de tyrannosaurus rex 1 c'est juste trop
balèze vous êtes dans le crétacé
supérieur d'amérique et l'empreinte elle
est balèze donc voilà comment on sait
qu'on regarde une empreinte de
tyrannosaurus rex est donc la seule fois
où on a découvert des empreintes de pas
de tyrannosaurus rex
parallèle c'est ce qui vous est
représentée ici voilà trois empreintes
une empreinte deux empreintes donc c'est
que dalle en fait
donc oui elles sont orientées dans une
direction parallèle on a donc trois
individus qui allait dans une même
direction
donc possiblement voyage et il en semble
potentiellement était-il seulement
intéressé par la même chose
ont-ils sont ils passés par là en même
temps
trois questions qui ne trouveront pas de
réponse le
et là c'est la totalité de ce qui
indiquerait que tyrannosaurus rex
pourrait chasser en meute 1 ce que je
vous montre sur cette diapos là c'est la
totalité du registre fossile de ce qui
pourrait possiblement indiqué que
tyrannosaurus rex chasser en meute
trouver des maccabées tous ensemble ne
veut rien dire vous le verrez quand on
verra la taphonomie dans les prochaines
vidéos trouvées des maccabées tous
ensemble ça ne veut rien dire ça veut
juste dire ça veut juste dire qu'ils
sont morts ensemble est encore peut-être
même pas si ça se trouve ils sont morts
ou quatre coins de la au quatre coins du
monde et c'est une immense inondations
qui a rassemblé les corps tous ensemble
dans un même trou donc trouvé des
cadavres tous ensemble ça nage mais et
ça ne démontrera jamais que des animaux
vivaient ensemble et encore moins qu'il
chassait ensemble
ça qu'il faut se le tenir pour dit c'est
ce que j'avais déjà expliqué dans ma
vidéo les théropodes ne chassait pas en
meute on n'a pas de preuve jusqu'à
présent
robuste que les théropodes chasser en
meute même pas les raptor surtout pas
aller raptor d'ailleurs les raptor on
n'a qu'un seul acte de chasse qui est
préservée réellement dans le registre
fossile et c'est le fameux fossiles du
vélociraptor en train de s'entretuer
avec le proto ceratops
6e velociraptor avait été accompagnée
d'autres de ses congénères il aurait
tout bouffer ses congénères donc ce la
seule raison pour laquelle ces deux
crétins se sont entretués c'est parce
que le velociraptor il était tout seul
et qu'une fois qu'ils se sont entretués
bailly s'est rien passé il ya eu zéro
charognards par les congénères ses
congénères l'ont pas aidé ces voix là
et à la rigueur il ya là il ya le cul du
proto ceratops qui manque peut-être
parce qu'il ya eu charognarde mais
longtemps après et encore on n'a pas
retrouvé de dents ou d'empreinte dedans
qui montre qui est le chat rognage donc
c'est peut-être juste le cul qui est qui
s'est fait et rodez d'une façon ou d'une
autre
au niveau du comportement du coup qu'est
ce qui serait le plus on va dire
indicateur d'une vie en société chez les
ch et les tyrannosaures basse et les
traces de morsures sur le museau au
final ça cesse à ses empreintes
parallèle là elle pourrait être
indicatif de tout et de n'importe quoi
comme je vous l ai dit mais ce qui nous
indique qu'il y avait au moins des
phases par moments de vie en société
chez les tyrannosaures ce sont ces
traces de morsures ce traces de morsures
dont qui pouvait être éducation des
petits indication de la dominance
parade nuptiale enfin pas parade
nuptiale mais en l'occurrence
combat pour pour conquérir des femelles
ou des mâles en fonction de qui se
battait réellement parce que on a
retrouvé ses empreintes de dedans autant
sur le mort feu robuste que sur le
morpho gracile donc le mort feu robuste
et en les femelles su poser le feu grâce
il est temps les mâles supposé on a
retrouvé ses morsures sur les deux morts
donc on ne sait pas à quoi servaient ces
morsures et si s'il s'agissait bien de
morsures social ça indique qu'au mois
dans une phase de la vie des
tyrannosauridés supposément la phase où
ils se battent pour conquérir des
femelles ou des mâles enfin pour
conquérir des der produits pour pour
accéder à la reproduction on va dire au
moins à ce moment là de leur vie ils
étaient ils étaient en interaction
sociale et on en retrouve beaucoup chez
les juvéniles ce qui suggère c'est ce
qui est suggéré la en arrière-plan en
fait c'est que les juvéniles
on en retrouve beaucoup chez eux ce qui
veut dire que le y avait aussi peut-être
des phases de jeu entre les juvéniles
crac crac il se mordait comme phase de
jeu je rappelle aussi que l'on à cette
fameuse allongement de la jna qui est de
la cochlée du cou qui est supposé être
un indicateur aussi d'une certaine forme
de communication sociale
20 pas verbal vocalement verbales mais
n'a
vocal donc mais on la retrouve aussi
bien on retrouve ça aussi chez le
crocodile donc ça peut être très très
limitées dans le temps les crocodiles le
soin parental c'est je ramasse les
petits je les ramène à l'eau je les
surveille deux heures et puis je me
casse donc le soin parental chez les
crocos s'est pas non plus voilà donc il
est possible que tyrannosaure se soit
limité à ça aussi mais apparemment les
juvéniles avait l'air d'interagir entre
eux et de se mordre entre eux et si
c'était en partant du principe qu'il
s'agissait de morsures social pour
accéder à la reproduction
les petits n'avaient pas de raison de se
bourrer la gueule entre eux si ce n'est
pour s'entraîner plus tard à la morsure
social en vue de la reproduction et donc
et donc donc ce serait une fonction de
jeu et d'apprentissage en fait et cette
perspective je trouve est fascinante
donc pourquoi pas un petit peu de
socialité quand ils sont jeunes pourquoi
pas un petit peu de socialité quand ils
sont adultes c'est ce que suggère ce
ses morsures mais tout ce qu'on a comme
preuve c'est des morsures ça se trouve
c'est pas des morsures social ça se
trouve il s'était juste des [ __ ] de
cannibales de l'enfer
c'est ça aussi le problème
si ça se trouve c'était juste des
[ __ ] de cannibales de l'enfer
c'était l'hypothèse originale avant
alors c'est pas brand en 2021 qui a des
mots qui a proposé ça c'était avant
curie et c'était philippe cury et je
sais plus qui qui avait publié en 1996
je crois pour la première fois que est
peut-être que c'est pas du cannibalisme
excès des morsures social en fait tu
vois donc avant que si j'avais fait
cette conférence avant 96 je vous aurais
dit c'était des [ __ ] de cannibales de
l'enfer quoi
on peut conclure les comportements de
tyrannosaurus
les organes des sens de tyrannosaurus le
registre fossile du cerveau de
tyrannosaurus qu'est-ce qui nous
indiquent ils nous indiquent des soies
parentaux minimum
mais avec quelques petites interactions
sociales au moins comparable à ce qu'on
voit chez les crocodiles donc ce qu'on
en voit dans préhistorique planète en
fait et je penche la dose la plus
satisfaisante de soins parentaux qu un
tyrannosaurus peu montré contrairement à
the lost world ou là donc jurassique pas
jurassic park 2 qui va peut-être un peu
trop loin sur le toit parental voilà le
soin parental rudimentaire convoi entre
le tyrannosaurus adultes et juvéniles
dans préhistorique planète je pense est
quelque chose de relativement correcte
même si je me suis beaucoup plaint qu'on
voyait trop de soins parental c'est
relativement correct avec un peu plus de
morsures sociale par contre ça ça
j'insiste il faudrait un peu plus de
morsures social dans préhistorique
planète y en a pas assez il devrait
avoir des cicatrices en fait pas le
plein la tronche
et puis au niveau de la chasse bon bah
déjà
charognards ou pas charognards aux
chasseurs chasseurs définitivement on a
les preuves fossiles je vous ai montré
la vertèbre mais évidemment qu'il y à
d'autres traces de morsures cicatriser
sur des proies potentielles de
tyrannosaurus je vous ai juste montrer
la meilleure en fait la meilleure preuve
mais il y en a plein d'autres comme vous
ai dit le registre fossile des morsures
de tyrannosaurus fin de tyrannosauridés
et de tyrannosaurus inclus est
absolument colossal
donc ya pas tellement de doutes sur le
fait que c'était un chasseur
probablement un chasseur embusqués et
pas il n'y a pas grand chose pour
indiquer qu'il chassait en
qu'il chasser en meute et certainement
pas comme on a pu le voir dans beaucoup
de documentaires il ya des gens qui ont
proposé que effectivement il ya des gens
il ya des paléontologues qui ont proposé
que effectivement c'était les juvéniles
qui chassait parce que les juvéniles et
est plus agile c'est là que les
tyrannosaures adultes qui sont ils sont
massifs vous imaginez le poids d'un
éléphant sur juste de pâtes il n'était
pas capable non plus de d'acrobaties
quoi les machins donc ils s'imaginaient
du coup que les juvéniles et est plus
agile que c'était les juvéniles qui
chassait et que c'était ensuite les
adultes qui venait comme dans une comme
chez les lions voilà les adultes imposer
leur force bas dégagent les juvéniles et
se nourrissent de la carcasse
c'est purement spéculatif on n'a aucune
preuve de ça et comme je les dis la
sueur au niveau du comportement au
niveau des preuves comportementale et du
cerveau et des de la paléo neurologie en
général tout indique que les juvéniles
apparemment vivait entre eux les
morsures social qu'on voit sur les
juvéniles sont des morsures sociales
faites par des juvéniles sur des
juvéniles il ya très très peu de
morsures d'adultes sur des juvéniles
il y en a mais il y en a très peu donc
apparemment les adultes et juvéniles ne
vivaient pas ensemble
d'après ce qu'on peut en juger encore
une fois par les morsures social ils ne
vivaient pas ensemble et si encore une
fois il s'agit de morsures sociale et
pas de cannibalisme mais ceci dit si
c'était du cannibalisme on s'attendrait
à ce que les adultes cannibalise les
juvéniles or ça n'a pas l'air d'être le
cas voilà donc
peut-être une bonne raison justement
d'exclure le cannibalisme et donc les
aides les adultes devait chasser en
embûches étant donné leurs capacités à
leur incapacité à pouvoir traquer les
proies
leur lenteur générale et il devait donc
attribuer une morsure gagnante sur ses
proies donc première morsure la première
morsure marche il attrape la truelle le
truc est mort il s'échappe le truc qui
est sauf voilà donc une morsure gagnante
on écrase et on déguste et donc là de ce
point de vue là je ce que le
comportement de chasse le plus probable
qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent dans dans un
contenu dans un contenu mainstream c'est
jurassic park 1 quand il se jette sur le
troupeau de gally mumu st-gall hymus il
ya peut-être pas assez de viande pour
nourrir un tyrannosaure il ya eu des
estimations intéressante sur la quantité
de viande qu'il fallait pour nourrir un
tyrannosaure est en réalité tyrannosaure
-2 -2 je crois qu'ils avaient déterminé
un truc du genre moins de 200 ou 300 kg
ça vaut pas l'effort en fait d'aller le
bouffer
mais mais bref donc d'où là d'où l'idée
aussi qu'il devait forcément se nourrir
de gros animaux relativement lent
mais bref la scène de chasse de galim us
à mon avis la plus précise ils chassent
en embûches
une morsure gagnante il le scoop à ce
que c'est relativement léger comme
animal mais il le scoop à ce que ses
dents sont profondément enracinées dans
son maxillaire donc il peut secouer le
machin sans se déboîter les chicots
et puis donc une morsure gagnante le
machin est mort voilà ça ça ça me semble
une représentation relativement
raisonnable de la stratégie de chasse
d'un tyrannosaurus voilà c'est tout pour
cette vidéo sur tyrannosaurus elle était
très longue mais c'est un animal
fascinant dont je ne pouvais pas laisser
quoi que ce soit côté je suis sûr que
j'en ai laissé plein de côté que vous
aurez plein de questions n'hésitez pas à
les poser en commentaire et je vous dis
à très bientôt pour notre dernier cours
de paléo neurologie mais pas la fin de
notre fil rouge de l'été petite surprise
ciao